It's not that tight.
The Joe Rogan experience
my day,
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
I'm not sure.
Before you talked to somebody as a good idea,
it seems jarring.
It seems like all of a sudden like you have to like talk it down so it becomes
like a conversation again because otherwise it's like,
oh,
what the fuck just right.
You are a neuroscientist or a cognitive neuroscientists.
Would that not affect the way your brain?
Absolutely.
Hearing sort of,
you know,
call to actions will change how you then react to things.
Fucks with you,
right?
Yeah,
absolutely.
That's something.
Yup.
We were talking a doctor,
Andrew Hill is on the podcast today and uh,
we were talking before the podcast started.
I didn't want to talk to you anymore.
I wanted to get you in here and sit you down because you said something really
fascinating that you take people who may have problems with substances and you
instead of getting them to abstain,
you get them to use them responsibly,
which is,
yeah.
An alien concept in this day and age.
Yeah.
I mean,
this is not terribly common in substance abuse,
you know,
sort of treatment world.
There's a few companies that do it and one of them is here in Los Angeles
alternatives and we uh,
we'll take people that,
you know,
might have an issue with alcohol let's say.
And uh,
the only,
only option is not abstinence for our program.
We have moderation options,
control,
do you stock options,
harm reduction.
So someone might come in and say,
you know,
look,
I'm a,
I consider myself an alcoholic but I want to start drinking again.
Or you know,
I'm someone who has been abstinent for a long time and struggles with craving
struggles with,
you know,
choice and whenever I slipped I slept big.
Helped me figure out how to not be that guy,
how to use responsibly or to not use.
So we don't necessarily say you must be a moderate user or you must abstain.
We ask clients what they want to do and then help them figure out how to get
there.
And for many of them,
they come to us because we do offer a moderation,
moderate alcohol use approach.
That is a,
that seems pretty novel is,
is it,
I mean,
it is pretty novel.
Yeah.
One of our principals,
Dr Mark Kern,
has been doing addiction work with moderation focus for about 30 years,
uh,
in La.
And so it's not just,
you know,
the newest thing ever,
but it's newer than Aa of course,
which has been around for,
you know,
pushing a hundred years now.
Yeah.
Aa people seem to think that that's the only way to go.
You have to do the 12,
10 step program.
You have to call everybody you ever wrong.
Do you have to pray to Jesus?
You have to drink a lot of coffee and smoke cigarettes.
Yeah.
It must be.
I mean,
you know,
uh,
the biggest difference,
for an alternatives approach or a harm reduction or moderation approach compared
to Aa and in my perspective,
is that a lot of the AI approaches disempowering.
You must give up control,
you know,
surrender,
surrender.
Um,
and I think that there's another option out there and that's architecting more
control,
more power.
Let's figure out your cues for overdrinking.
Let's figure out what happens,
you know,
why do you get to five or six or seven drinks,
like what happens on drink?
Um,
you know,
what are the triggers for like going home and automatically driving into that
liquor store parking lot you always pass by.
So we help people figure out all the different triggers and cues that are
driving they're out of control use and what control use might look like for
them.
You know,
what sort of appropriate mindful drinking might look like for them.
Um,
and it's,
if it's alcohol,
people spend the first month with us abstaining anyways just to reset tolerance
because uh,
to be good at moderation,
you have to be good at abstinence.
So the goals may not be abstinence always in our alcohol program,
but everyone takes a month off,
reset their tolerance,
you know,
get some sort of Clearhead,
uh,
it gets their sleep fixed.
Um,
and we're doing other things besides the alcohol interventions in therapy and
biofeedback and mindfulness and,
and other,
you know,
sort of whole team approach.
But then at the end of that month,
if folks decided they want to,
we go to a bar with them,
sit down,
they order a drink,
we can,
my breathalyzer and they have their first drink and we,
you know,
they get breathalyzed every drink with them.
Um,
not at this,
no,
no.
Uh,
later,
um,
you know,
I don't typically go to the bars with our clients.
Um,
there's,
there's some legal issues with drinking with them.
Like when we go to a bar with them,
we buy lunch and they buy the alcohol to avoid.
So you can't even buy it.
We don't provide the drugs and alcohol.
Yeah,
of course.
So do they drink by themselves sometimes?
Um,
a lot of the clients that we work with carry around little breathalyzers and
their pocket that several times a day picking them and ask them to blow and get
a little a camera snapshot and you know,
it is them and a GPS location.
And so we turned them where they are,
who they are and what their blood alcohol is.
And you know,
unlike most other treatment programs,
if you blow dirty on a breathalyzer,
it's usually like you're out of here.
But that's,
it's like,
oh great.
So you drank,
what was that like?
I see you got this blood alcohol level and how many drinks does that,
was that too?
Okay,
interesting.
How over what timeframe,
how did that feel?
And we get people to,
in a very structured way,
analyze what alcohol is instead of it being sort of momentum,
uh,
you know,
based behavior.
The,
the,
there's a certain amount of like pull that something has a drawn,
attracted and an energy to something that's forbidden.
Yeah.
And that,
that is very problematic for people that are addicts.
Yeah.
I've seen it firsthand many times where people just have this overwhelming
desire to do with,
they're not supposed to do almost because it's like the pressure of abstaining.
Yeah.
It's just overwhelming.
It's like that,
that issue.
Oh,
it's always a cloud hovering over them.
Yeah.
Also things that are forbidden,
become attractive and the conversation about them get shut down a little bit
when things get sort of,
you know,
putting these little isolated bullet walks of um,
dangerous and forbidden.
So it's hard to talk about,
you know,
problematic alcohol use if any alcohol use is considered problematic.
Yeah.
It becomes one of those things where everyone,
this very rigid idea of what an alcoholic is supposed to do.
And if you bring up something like what you're proposing or what you actually
not just propose but you enact and treatment,
that's got to receive a lot of criticism.
It does.
And you know,
we get long term sort of 12 step type saying you're going to kill people.
People are going to,
you know,
problems.
The thing is,
you know,
we've done some research in our center and folks self-select abstinent track or
moderation track and the self selection appears to be what drives success,
not which track you're on.
So if people identify their goals,
we help them reach those goals.
But if your only goals are,
or if you only allowable path is you must be abstinent,
then you aren't taught any skills about how to drink a little bit,
you know,
so when people who are on an abstinent only sort of treatment programs have
slips,
they have big slips,
they just say,
okay,
I'm off the track.
Ooh,
let's just pound it back.
There's that.
There's that discounting or you know,
I've screwed up once.
Might as well just go for it.
And there's also the piece about skills we have.
They don't know how to drink two or three or four drinks if all they do is
abstain.
Now the common thought on genetics and addiction is that certain people have
just a predisposition for alcoholism,
for drug addiction.
Is that a fact?
Yeah.
There's a,
I'm an opioid receptor in the brain.
Um,
I forgot to them.
You are the capital one of the opiod receptors in the brain.
Uh,
there's one genetic sort of flavor you can have where alcohol is extra
rewarding,
where it just is,
you know,
you love that sensation and you'll love the feeling a little more than the
average person might.
So,
but is it just that,
is it just they love it more?
Well,
it's,
it's more rewarding and therefore learning is reinforced.
I mean,
rewarding meaning that what you find repetitive or interesting or Yummy.
MMM.
If you find things extra yummy,
then your behavior is modified to get more of that thing,
you know?
Right.
But the way I've always thought of it,
I don't have a genetic predisposition to alcoholism and I've had friends who do,
and there's this weird thing that happens.
So then when you see them drink,
where they,
they go,
juror belies,
you know,
where they're like,
no one's there.
They're sharp guys.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Are you looking at it?
You're like,
where are you man?
Are you in there like get,
you literally don't see them anymore?
Well,
these folks are probably,
you know,
thoroughly into a hardcore drinking,
lifestyle,
right?
This is not their first big slipping a long time.
This is sort of uh,
uh,
you know,
go to the bar after work every day or go to the liquor store and grab a half
bottle of wine every day.
This is,
you know,
reinforced to behavior.
Um,
I don't think even someone with those genes would have sort of a checkout or
some,
you know,
lack of sudden self control,
their first drink after I've standing for awhile.
It's the,
the behavioral sort of slippery slope that we get on that causes the problem and
folks that have this extra rewarding effect from alcohol,
you know,
get pulled down that slip faster,
but it's still not,
you know,
predetermined.
You're not going to become an alcoholic just
because you have a more rewarding effect from alcohol or something else.
See,
I was always confused.
I didn't think that it was a reward issue.
All right.
I thought,
and this is based entirely on,
you know,
just talking to people.
So no research obviously,
but I always thought it was just something happens to them where they cannot
help themselves.
That's,
is that just the common way of discussing it because of the 12 step treatment
program?
Ideal?
Yeah.
I think partially there's this idea of,
well,
you're powerless over alcohol,
therefore,
except that you're powerless.
But a lot of that powerlessness or I can't control my behavior is because of the
sort of overlearning that comes where behavior is no longer a choice.
It's almost automatic because you've gotten so rewarded so many times from that
behavior that then the behavior becomes reinforced.
I mean,
I,
you know,
it all,
addiction is this way,
but all addiction is just learning.
It's not some special form of learning.
It's just learning.
So what you're talking about is people that have learned to lose control.
So there's that.
Like there's the common myths thought about native Americans.
The common,
um,
uh,
discussion when people talk about native Americans and alcohol is that they
didn't have alcohol in their diet.
We introduced it to them with the Europeans restaurant,
introduced it to them,
and then they became almost instantly addicted because they did not have the
genetic predisposition to process it.
Yeah.
And that's,
yes,
I think it's partially bs.
I think it's more about,
you know,
if you lock a bunch of people on a small plot of a non farmable land and don't
get them any mechanisms for advancement and take away all their power and then
give them the drug to abuse,
they abuse it.
You know,
there's all these studies showing that if you give a a rat unfettered access to
drugs and alcohol,
it sits there and you know,
it's the lever until it dies,
right?
That's actually not true.
If you give a rat access to cocaine or alcohol dependent alcohol,
but something really rewarding,
um,
it will only self administer the drug in the,
you know,
and,
and sort of starve to death for the reward when the environment is an
interesting,
when the environment's impoverished,
if there's lots of,
you know,
wrap toys and lots of other acute rats hanging out,
they're much less interested in becoming an cocaine addicts or whatever it is.
Um,
it's only in the absence of stimulating,
enriched environments do these sort of automatic behaviors takeover.
So I would argue at least partially the native American alcohol connection is
because these are decent people who are disenfranchised systematically and then
given an escape.
You know,
I had that discussion recently with Dr Chris Ryan and one of the things,
he's the author of sex at dawn,
very interesting book,
but one of the things that he brought up is the environment itself that they do
these studies on rats.
They're in a cage,
they're in a case is for lesson lights and there's people in lab coats or
hovering over them.
Right.
It's about is unnatural as you can get.
Yup.
And any escape that they could probably seek,
you know,
to,
to try exactly.
Mitigate the stress that they're under.
I mean,
it's a completely unnatural environment.
It's not like you're giving them cocaine out in the wild.
Right.
If you did exactly that,
they
probably,
they probably wouldn't go after it.
Yeah.
I mean,
um,
if you put some toys in their cage,
they stopped self administering to the same degree.
There's not as interested in,
I mean,
addiction is not the goal.
The reward isn't necessarily the goal.
When things are interesting novel,
when you can explore your environments,
right?
So their brains are programmed to seek out food,
to seek out sex and to seek out shelter.
And when all those things are screwed up because they're in this completely
unnatural environment,
they don't know what to do.
Yeah,
exactly.
I mean,
and,
and this,
this is not just rats and humans were given this.
Well,
if you're an alcoholic,
if you're a drinker,
a problem drinker,
you're always going to be a problem.
Drinker is the prevailing wisdom,
which also isn't true.
Something like 90,
95% of people that are problem drinkers learn to not be problem drinkers with no
programs,
with no intervention,
no therapy.
It's learn to get control over their drinking.
Do you think that that,
that's a really interesting point.
It's a really interesting point when you think about,
um,
people that look forward to happy hour and we look forward to that drink after
work.
Like how many boring jobs we've turned people into alcoholics because yeah,
while they're at work all day,
they're just constantly itching away at their natural reward systems.
Just God,
something,
I got to get something in here.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And boredom and lack of ability to tolerate boredom or tolerate uncomfortable
emotions of which,
you know,
boredom can be one is often the biggest driver for problematic substance use.
Wow.
Boredom,
boredom or marriage.
That's why dudes get drunk when they're married.
Well,
it's probably one of the reasons it's a big one,
right?
Yeah.
That is amazing that,
you know,
and it's that that story has always been that story of the tests with the rats
and the cocaine has been just sort of repeated ad nauseum.
Sure.
Does the point where everybody repeats it.
And until Chris Ryan brought it up that way,
I,
I never really thought about it.
I just thought,
wow.
Cocaine's a super addictive.
And then he brought it up that way.
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
we have,
we got,
of course they're in a fucking cage.
Right.
They're all stressed out.
Freaked out.
No wonder whether doing blow.
Yeah,
exactly.
Right.
And you know,
and things like cocaine,
math,
the psycho stimulant class of drugs,
um,
they affect a neurotransmitter or primarily called dopamine.
And dopamine is the reward signal.
It's the interest salients appetitive you know,
when you see a hot girl,
you get dope me and bump.
When you eat an ice cream sandwich,
you got dopamine bump.
When you do a line of blow,
you get a dopamine bump and a second one from the direct,
you know,
cocaine affecting the dopamine system.
So the stimulant class is sort of so addictive because it's pleasurable and
because it directly modifies the dopamine and sort of system.
So you get a one,
two,
I was a double a reward if you will.
And do you apply the same sort of treatment protocol with cocaine that you do
with alcohol?
Don't know.
Um,
you know,
there's a bunch of reasons why a,
for things that are sort of drugs of abuse,
like cocaine,
meth,
you know,
we would probably ask folks to abstain or encourage them to,
but there's some other drugs you can abstain from.
You know,
someone's on like drugs for pain,
medication,
a pain management or psychiatric drugs they need to take for whatever reason.
Um,
we would do it more a harm reduction approach for drugs,
prescribed drugs that have become a drugs abuse,
but for recreational drugs of abuse,
like cocaine,
um,
you know,
there's,
there's legal and ethical issues with offering a moderate cocaine is,
well,
what if cocaine was legal then we would then you would like,
can,
it's only on a bus for instance,
is sort of right on that edge of,
uh,
you know,
being legal or not.
And we would offer a cannabis moderation if someone was legally using cannabis,
you know?
Um,
and if we were in Colorado or Washington state,
we'd be offering cannabis as an equal moderate player,
so to speak,
with our alcohol program.
What does that concern you that the only reason why you don't use cocaine and
that way is that
it's illegal?
Well,
I mean,
I think a lot of people can get in trouble with cocaine,
um,
in a way they aren't going to get in trouble with weed.
So I think the bar for risk versus harm versus,
you know what we're,
we're uh,
potentially the,
the,
the cost of failure is much higher for some of these heavier drugs.
So we're never going to offer like a heroin moderation program,
but he's an alcohol equally bad for you.
When you look at statistics of abuse and the health consequences,
alcohol seems to rank right up there with heroin.
There are more alcohol abusers as that what it is then there are heroin abusers
and people don't,
don't abuse heroin from like an age 12 to age 80.
Right.
At high levels.
I mean we,
people can have used alcohol their whole lives at high level and survive and
survive somehow or you know,
manage,
that's not going to be the case with cocaine or heroin or major opiates or
stimuli.
Now when you talk about opiates of course in this country and today you,
you consider pills cause this is the new form of distribution.
Have you ever seen that?
Um,
the documentary,
um,
uh,
the oxycontin express,
I have not.
It is a really fascinating piece that they did and it actually helped alter the
law in Florida because Florida has to have those.
You're aware of the whole situation in Florida.
I'm sure they had pain management centers for folks who don't know and these
pains,
pain management centers were essentially one stop heroin shops.
Yeah,
they'd give it to you in pill form,
but you would go there.
There would be a doctor right there and he'd say,
hey doctor,
my back's all fucked up.
All right,
well you need pain pills.
And then you would go,
literally,
you would exit his door and go to the next door and that was run by the same
company and it was a pain management facility,
pharmacy.
And he'd go in there and all they had was pills and you would just go and buy
oxycontin's and there was all these people waiting outside.
Vanguard did the show,
uh,
on it and a,
it was amazing.
It was amazing because they followed people who are hooked on it.
They followed people that were going hopping from clinic to clinic and it was
just rampant.
Florida had some ungodly percentage of people that were prescribed a oxycontin.
Yeah,
of course.
Elders
are also mean.
Florida.
Half the state is elders and pain management is much more common.
Painted pediment in the medical sort of space as much more common when you're 78
years old and it is when you're 30 or 40,
it's very important when you say elders at you say age and not Mormons.
Yes.
Um,
uh,
not the,
not,
not the quorum of 12,
whatever.
No.
Uh,
like,
like people 60,
65 and up is what I consider elders.
I have some friends that are Mormon and w we were over their house and some
elders came over and they were in their twenties.
Yeah.
There,
there,
this is elder John and this is the elder Wilson.
Like get the fuck out of here.
I'm not calling you elder.
Yeah.
I have a buddy who's a,
it was a Jack Mormon,
you know,
a lapsed Mormon and uh,
he's just,
you know,
55 year old guy with dreadlocks down to his ankles and you know,
musician and he left the Mormon Church but he was an elder and he's like early
twenties,
before he sort of decided it wasn't for him.
Yeah.
He could have used some heroin.
Got Him off that early maybe.
Um,
so you think that if more people had heroin you would see health consequences,
um,
of far worse than what they are of alcohol?
I do,
yeah.
I think,
I think it'd be hard for people to abuse high levels of opiates without their
life falling apart very quickly.
And this is true,
mean some people get into alcohol and go downhill very fast.
Other people get into alcohol and never have a problem with it.
Even drinking high levels.
Well what concerns me about those pills more than anything else is I've had
friends that don't have problems with anything else.
And they got on pain pills and then uhmm including a,
there's a family member that I have just got,
got injured at work,
got on pills for his back and then gone.
Really Common Story.
It's bizarre.
It's like something steels who they are.
Yeah.
Once you're addicted to pain medication,
you know,
the doctors won't give it to you forever.
So at some point you're getting off the pain medication prescriptions,
but you might still be addicted.
So you seek,
you know,
street opiates and that's where they showed the standard story there.
So there's an itch that they can't scratch anymore and it just becomes
overwhelming after awhile.
Yeah,
exactly.
There's a lot of that.
The same thing,
sort of this psychological pull of something that's forbidden or something that
you're not supposed to do or is there is a physical component too.
There's definitely a physical component,
uh,
to addictions.
Um,
but you know,
the withdrawal symptoms and the,
I mean,
addiction is really two things.
It's dependence and tolerance and the tolerance you can get for some drugs very
quickly.
The dependence might not show up the same way for everybody.
Um,
but other folks may have dependence and withdrawal symptoms from low amounts.
Heroin is fairly addicting.
The withdrawal from heroin is brutal.
I believe the physiological addiction of nicotine might be greater than heroin,
but the withdrawals not as bad.
So the physical withdrawal,
the actual bid aches of your body.
Yeah.
Carl Hart described Dr Crawl Heart.
Um,
I forget the name of his book,
but he's been on the podcast before.
You remember his book?
Jamie,
doesn't matter.
It's an important,
um,
he said it was like having a bad flu.
He said,
yeah,
he said it's very overrated as far as the amount of pain you go through.
The flu kind of sucks.
It does kind of suck,
but everyone looks at it as if like,
it's this horrible bone aching.
Like I've never done oxycontin,
so I don't,
I don't know.
I've never done heroin,
so I,
I,
I'm just guessing we'll think about what the opiate system does endogenously
naturally in your body.
It helps you not feel pain.
It helps reduce pain and inflammation.
So if you've been abusing with super physiological levels,
massive opiates,
and then you withdraw them,
you're a pain reduction system is overly sort of,
you know,
sensitized and then you feel things as painful that were not considered painful
before.
So I think that a lot of that withdrawal is sort of resetting the opiate,
the endogenous pain management system.
Interesting.
So there's probably all sorts of weird little aches and pains that you are
already have that you're just completely unaware of.
And then they glaringly become obvious,
which is what happens when you get the flu.
And you know,
if you worked out the day before you feel like crap,
you know,
muscles or extra achy because now there's inflammation and you know,
spasms.
And I think all that probably happens too when you're withdrawing from massive
opiates.
Now when you get a guy like a rush limbo who famously was taking something like
90 pills a day,
something insane,
I don't remember what the number was,
but it was off the charts where he had his housekeeper would go out and buy him
the stuff.
And how does that happen?
Like how does one keep ramping it up?
Well,
I mean I think you have to be resourceful.
And I think you mentioned earlier where people,
you know,
clinic hopping or doctor hopping,
I mean that's a really common sort of way people abuse,
uh,
pain meds is to get multiple people to prescribe.
Um,
it sounds like,
you know,
rush may have had his friends and family,
helping to develop his habit.
Um,
when you're taking lots of different things though,
there's an added risk and that's what's called polypharmacy or interactions
between your drugs and a lot of painkillers.
A lot of major tranquilizers are very significant drugs that suppress the
cardiovascular system,
the respiratory system.
And so if you combine different types of drugs being given from different
doctors who aren't aware of the different drugs that you're being given,
then you can get into,
you know,
life threatening side effects very quickly.
For some people.
That was the big issue in Florida was that they didn't have a database of until
recently.
So you could go to one doctor,
get your prescription and go right down the street to another doctor and they
couldn't share information.
So you'd never know,
hey,
this guy already has prescription.
He's going crazy and he's getting pills all over town.
Yeah.
And you know,
to some extent those little pharmacy slash prescription shops,
uh,
they,
they remind me of,
you know,
the,
uh,
cannabis culture we have in most states now where,
you know,
you can walk in to a little mom and pop sort of prescription center where you,
maybe you see a doctor,
maybe you see their nurse practitioner,
you pay your 40 bucks,
he walk out with a car,
do you go next door and you put your card down and walk out with your weed.
You know,
nowadays you go online and you say,
I'd like this strain delivered at my door at this time,
and it shows up at your door with a smile and a little mint.
It's a very different sort of way to deal with drugs.
Then the gatekeeper of the physician who's carefully paying attention to your
full use spectrum and managing your life,
managing your health with some good perspective on you.
When we have these,
you know,
as you mentioned that in the short time we have 10 minutes with the doctor or
something and it's a prescription out the door.
Yeah,
the will.
The cannabis one is kind of a joke because although there are people,
I'm going to know people that use it for health reasons,
the vast majority are Juke in the system.
They're just like,
hey,
I got a headache.
Free Pot stress.
Stress is one of the biggest detriments to health.
You know,
cortisol rises,
your hippocampus dies and cells fall apart and your body heals less fast and you
learn less.
Well,
your frontal lobe shuts down.
Stress is a big problem.
So,
you know,
I would argue that even the recreational cannabis users who sort of gamed the
system are getting the stress reduction benefits from it typically.
Oh No,
I would agree with you most certainly.
I also think that life itself is a disease.
You need a drug to treat life itself.
Yeah,
maybe a desirable difficulty.
It's just ridiculous.
Well the,
the,
the pressures of the average nine to five existence plus traffic commute,
Bill's family is an overwhelming,
I don't,
I don't believe that our bodies are designed for this.
And I think that any means that you can without completely destroying your body
and mitigating whatever pressures and stresses you're under.
I'm all for it.
I mean I think aspirin should be legal.
I,
I'm,
I'm a big fan of almost everything being legal,
but I think that some folks are going to have a much harder time with certain
substances than others.
Yeah.
And that's individual variability is part of it.
You know,
the genetics your show up with.
It's also things like your,
your environment.
You know,
what you see used,
how you use,
why you use,
you are using because you want to feel comfortable or euphoric or have some good
time or watch a movie and find it extra interesting.
Are using a shutdown,
the pain and boredom of your life cause they're very dramatically different ways
of using substances.
And are you using it to mitigate the effects of trauma,
especially trauma from your childhood,
which is one of the things that people don't consider when they talk in
disparaging ways about people being addicts.
They don't consider the fact that this person might have been wired in a certain
way because of traumatic experiences that they had while they're developing
where their mine was developing.
I see that all the tons represent that.
Yeah.
I mean I,
I do brain mapping qbeg and we look at sort of functional patterns in brains and
try to tie it together to people's behavior and the things that are struggling
with.
And I often see in people that are struggling with alcohol,
sort of a sensitization,
a hot spot on the back of the brain in an area called the posterior cingulate
Cortex,
which is to some extent involved with psych sensitization to threat noticing
danger and these that,
that,
that spot shows up that overactivity shows up when people have experienced
fairly significant trauma.
Um,
so it's a pretty common reason people are using drugs and alcohol.
And is there a way to mitigate that?
Is there a way to diminish the effects of Oh sure.
Yeah,
there's multiple ways.
It's a short answer.
Um,
I do a lot of neurofeedback or biofeedback on brainwaves,
so you might measure that like excess Beta excess fast activity back there.
It's not a stuck level.
It's,
it's always fluctuating moment to moment.
And so whatever it trends in the right direction goes down.
You make something happen,
make a chime play or a spaceship fly or a pack meet some dots,
but it fluctuates in the wrong direction.
A minute later in the PAC man stops and then the brain fluctuates in the right
direction.
The pacman continues,
the brain starts to go,
oh cool input.
Whenever I'm doing one thing and it does more of that one thing and this trains
down or trains up certain patterns in the brain to change regulatory modes.
Wow.
So what's the mechanism of this?
Like what's causing this?
Yeah,
well it's basic learning.
I mean when you were a baby flopping around and trying to learn how to walk,
there was a lot of random activity making your limbs move or semi random,
you know,
just trying random,
your brain was just gonna say it,
random pulses to see what happened.
And suddenly you put your arms down on the ground,
you push yourself up and you could see more.
You could see further into the distance.
Your brain went,
oh cool.
Remember this pattern of muscle activity?
Because this one gets me to,
you know,
see more stuff and explore the environment.
And it wasn't like some magical,
your brain went okay,
you know,
contract,
the left bicep and then the left forearm.
It just kind of happens randomly until it produces the desired effect,
which is,
oh,
I'm sort of crawling now.
And then the brain does more of the thing that let it get more input,
you know,
avoid danger,
get pleasure,
whatever the,
you know,
learning reinforcers are the same thing happens when you're sitting in front of
a biofeedback machine.
Try and make a spaceship fly or a car race around a track with your brain.
Um,
you want it to happen.
And so whenever the car,
you know,
slows down and Peter's out next to the race course cause your brain got
distracted or tents,
the brain doesn't like the lack of input and it starts to go,
hey wait,
where's my,
where's my input?
And it tries to figure out,
oh,
I'm controlling this environment out in the world,
therefore I should do more of x,
less of y.
It's,
it's a,
it's actually a noncognitive process.
Believe it or not.
You weren't trying,
you're more sort of letting it happen.
We're instrumentally or shaping,
conditioning the brain in certain directions and there are there certain
triggers that could potentially bring you back to the negative state that you
were in because of the trauma?
Like are there things that people have to avoid once they go through this
process to keep from,
for biofeedback?
No,
not generally.
The neurofeedback or biofeedback processes typically changing the brain and
changing it permanently.
Permanently.
It's kind of like if,
you know,
if you were limping because your left knee was off and he went to do six months
of physical therapy from then on you're walking with appropriate gate and you're
always practicing the new muscles and coordination and things.
So,
uh,
neurofeedback isn't permanent for everything.
There's an active disease process going on like schizophrenia or HIV or
something.
Then the problems you able to reduce can reemerge.
But if your gut like ADHD or migraines or sleep issues or anxiety or trauma or
OCD or PTSD or you know,
these things all do appear to change and change in a largely permanent way for
most people.
Wow.
That's amazing.
That's incredible.
And how long has this process,
like say if you take someone who's had a traumatic childhood and issues with
abuse and substance abuse because of that,
and then they enter into some sort of a treatment like this.
How,
how long of a process?
Yeah,
most of my clients start off with,
um,
some,
uh,
training program.
It's to going to the gym if you go to the gym once every so often doesn't do
much.
So I asked my clients to come in two or three times a week for about 30 sessions
total.
And that's enough.
30 sessions is enough typically to make one and a half to two standard
deviations of change.
Pretty big change.
So can take our dramatically ADHD person and give them control over their
attention management.
It can reregulate sleep,
eliminate migraines.
So 30 sessions as my answer to that question of well,
how long does it take?
30 sessions?
That seems really small,
you know,
three,
four times a week you might get it done.
And uh,
you know,
six,
seven,
eight weeks,
that's changed the,
eliminate your ADHD or anxiety or trauma.
Incredible.
Yeah.
Now what is ADHD?
What,
what exactly is it?
Because you hear people saying that it doesn't exist.
You hear people saying that it's just some way they diagnosed children so they
can give them medication.
There's some truth to that and there's some truth to the,
to the people saying it doesn't exist.
I think that as a path ology as a strictly a mental illness,
it doesn't really exist.
I think it was an exam.
I think what we have is a natural spectrum and continuum of attention management
resources.
And some of us can notice everything in the environment and turn our attention
and just be wide focused and be pulled off by all novelty.
And other folks are good at being heads down and sustained attention.
You know,
10,000 years ago we needed hunters who could like,
you know,
see the little,
the little tiger hiding in the corner or the hard,
you know,
red berry hall,
hard to spot piece of fruit hiding under the leaf who could notice all the
little environmental cues.
And we also need folks who could sit behind the village and like we'd the plant
all day long.
So I think that there's a natural sort of reinforcer of human,
you know,
a range of human attention regulation where some folks have more novelty
seeking,
more wide focus and other folks have more narrow or sustained attention.
So when we say Adhd,
you know,
the,
the diagnostic criteria,
uh,
in general and mental health isn't really about what's going on.
It's about what's going on and does it interfere with your life.
So you can be really hyperactive,
really spacey,
really checked out,
really,
you know,
hard to talk to.
But if you're successful,
I wouldn't call it a pathology,
I wouldn't even call it ADHD.
Um,
and to call it Adhd,
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder,
the deficit is,
implies you have less attention than average.
But you know,
we all know ADHD people that can sit and play video games without stopping for
20 hours straight.
That's not a deficit of attention.
That's a,
an excess of typical attention to some extent.
So it's really about managing your attention in ways that are appropriate to the
demands of the environment.
If you're a classroom teacher wants you to sit still for 45 minutes and you
can't,
then it's a problem.
It becomes a problem because of the classroom though,
doesn't it?
And if you aim as someone who has this issue with attention when it comes to
things that they're not into,
but yet they can focus extremely well on something that they're fascinated by
and then that benefits them and they become successful at that.
If you are in a negative environment as far as teaching or a school and they try
to get you to become this person who's just like everybody else,
then it becomes something they want to medicate you with.
Right.
And it could be mitigating away,
medicating away something that makes you unique and could actually benefit you
in your life.
Absolutely.
And there are benefits for having,
you know,
more abstract thought and more novelty seeking and be able to integrate,
abstract concepts,
especially for artists,
especially people that aren't,
you know,
like I'm,
I'm for instance,
horrible at math.
I cannot do math in my head.
I'm dyscalculus,
but I'm verbally about as good as it gets.
And so,
you know,
I was always sort of not rewarded by being in math classes and really rewarded
being in,
you know,
language or,
whenever English class,
um,
the artist,
ADHD kid thrives in,
you know,
one 10th of their high school classes.
Um,
potentially if it's dramatic ADHD.
But you know,
I would say that most people don't have dramatic attention regulation issues.
They have minor attention regulation issues that can be changed.
Um,
the,
you mentioned that,
uh,
ADHD people can be fascinated with by things and really,
you know,
pay attention.
Um,
the prefrontal Cortex,
the most,
most frontal,
most anterior part of the brain,
the most human part,
the part that developed the latest is really the executive of the brain,
the CEO.
And a lot of how it does its job is by telling the rest of the brain,
no,
you know,
don't turn your head and look at this other thing.
Don't,
you know,
grab that woman.
Don't eat that food.
Don't you know,
it's,
no,
no.
It was a lot of the PFC does in Adhd,
the PFC is often underactive,
it's called it.
The CEO is asleep at the wheel and so other parts of the brain kind of takeover.
It's like the sensory system sees a pretty bird fly by and turns your head
before you know it because the CEO is not telling you not to.
Um,
this is why,
uh,
ADHD folks tend to really pursue activities that are dangerous.
You know,
skydiving,
motorcycle riding,
taking drugs,
risky sex because anything risky,
challenging,
dangerous,
lights up the PFC and really turns it on and activate it in a way that most ADHD
people don't experience.
Most of the time.
This is why if you have an Adhd kid,
they train parents to yell at them to create the conflict that then produces a
more active prefrontal cortex.
They train parents to yell at them.
Yeah.
Without even knowing it.
They,
they,
they train people around them to create conflict with them because being yelled
at,
being punished,
being,
you know,
engaged aggressively lights up the prefrontal cortex.
So they do behavior or they engage in behavior that will cause people to yell at
them subconsciously to get the reward of having a feeling alive,
a feeling on,
whoa,
that's freaky.
Now when you're dealing with people that have such an incredible amount of
variation,
the variation between human beings and personalities and you're sticking them in
a classroom and you're forcing them to adhere to some sort of a program that was
designed by someone who's never going to meet them.
And it's the same for everyone across the state core or something.
Yeah.
Something along those lines.
How damaging is that for someone's education?
I mean,
it seems to me that like it just seems that that sort of pressure to conform is
going to be met with resistance.
Yeah,
of course it will.
And the more unusual the you are,
the harder it will be to conform.
But I would say for most people,
you're still getting basic skills even in these sort of homogenized program.
And is there some benefit from just dealing with this homogenization and dealing
with the boarding,
the curriculum,
you know,
that they're forcing upon you just to give you just some,
some sort of sort of stress management benefits.
I mean,
you know,
it's certainly people management.
You can't teach every individual kid one on one.
Um,
and so there has to be an accommodation or a compromise somewhere for doing
classroom in a public school,
you know,
broad teaching.
Um,
I think technology is changing that.
I think the massively online,
you know,
courses that are mostly free these days,
um,
that's mostly adults taking those and taking it,
taking advantage of those.
But I think that will change how we teach children longterm.
It will allow more individualized.
You know,
if you take the traditional public school common core system on one end of the
spectrum and you look at something completely opposite,
like Montessori schools,
Montessori is all about finding the thing the kid is interested in and then
funneling all their learning down that one avenue of interest.
I love the idea behind that.
But Montessori also lumps all these ages together.
And a lot of weird social shit goes on when you have a 12 year old with a six
year old.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's,
you know,
but that's also a little bit more,
I mean,
I'm not sure that we need to segregate ages.
Uh,
you know,
we,
we create cohort effects,
people experience specific things because of the groups that are lumped in with.
That's a little artificial.
You know,
couple hundred years ago we had a six year old and a 12 year old and a 16 year
old in the same classroom and they probably all learned from each other even if
they didn't know it.
Right.
But aren't they all in different levels of six year old and a 12 year old,
they're going to be learning completely different maybe.
But at six years old I was learning like most 16 year olds.
Well,
you're a super genius dude.
you know,
hey,
thanks.
But uh,
but the point is that even within all bunch of six year olds,
you know,
class of,
what is that like third grade or something,
you know,
you've got some that are functioning several years below their level.
And some of their functioning many years above their level,
the first intelligence tests were really age norm tests.
They said,
you know,
here are your functioning compared to your chronological age.
Where's your mental age?
That was the first sort of round of intelligence tests that were created.
Um,
it was all about age,
you know,
developmental age versus chronological age.
But it would seem to me that it would be incredibly different.
I'm not that aware of the Montessori system other than friends that have kids in
it that have complaints.
But I would think that the,
the variability would be so large that if you have a classroom of 2030 kids,
how are you going to pay attention to each kid's needs?
You're going to have to multiple teachers.
You do.
And,
and in Montessori you tend to have smaller classroom sizes with w with more
teachers,
teacher's aides,
Montessori assistance.
You know,
in a public school you might have one teacher for 35 kids if you're lucky,
if you're locked in and in a Montessori program with 25 or 30 kids,
you probably have four or five adults in the room.
Knowing what you know about the mind and the development of the mine.
Is the current state of education,
public education in this country,
is that one of the more frustrating things that you have to consider?
Not really.
I mean,
people learn so many different ways and I also don't think that learning stops
when you're out of school.
So I think that the role of public education should be to do as much as possible
for as many people as possible.
But you know,
the people at either of the extremes are never going to be well served.
People that are struggling or people that are advanced are never going to be
well served by,
you know,
general public education.
While it's this sort of one to 35,
one to 40 ratio,
that was the point.
Why is it one to 35 to 40 and why does it receive such poor funding and why do
teachers receive such little respect?
I mean,
I'm a teacher.
I teach at Ucla and uh,
you know,
we get paid adequately as a lecturer,
college.
It's a college.
Um,
but even at that level,
you know,
the pay is not all that dramatically amazing.
Um,
I feel like,
you know,
like maybe you're implying that we should be paying people,
shaping our young people's minds a lot and,
and treasuring their roles.
It should be a huge honor.
Yeah.
Um,
we don't have that.
We don't tend to have a lot of traditional mechanisms left in our sort of modern
western culture.
We don't look at,
um,
you know,
coming of age or differences.
I mean,
women have an obvious coming of age thing that happens between like nine and 13.
There's a physiologic change,
so it's obvious.
Boys don't have that.
And so,
you know,
thousand years ago we hit 13 years old.
We were,
you know,
made men with some ritual and we don't let them,
hunted a bore,
who knows,
I've got a tattoo.
Uh,
but nowadays people go from being children to adults without any clear stages,
without the sort of social reinforcers of,
of where you are and what your life means in terms of the community,
in terms of your family.
So I think that's unfortunately,
you know,
it's a function of living on a planet with 7 billion people.
That's his topic that's been brought up on this show many,
many times.
Cause I'm a big,
I'm a big fan of an a big proponent of engaging in difficult activities to
understand yourself.
And I think that coming of age rituals,
they at the very least signified to a child.
Like now I am this.
Yeah.
In martial arts you get belts.
Yup.
And you know when you achieve,
you know your blue belt,
there's this moment where you get that belt,
you go,
wow,
I am a blue belt now.
And it doesn't seem like it should be much.
But I remember when I was doing Jujitsu and I went from a white pill to a blue
bottle.
It's like wow,
I got my blue belt.
But meanwhile I was exact same person.
Nothing had changed and you were recognized as different and in inch in
historical,
cultural sort of coming of age rituals,
the young person is given advice by all the men in the village.
All the women in the village,
they pick a new name.
Sometimes they go through like an ordeal.
I mean the,
the ordeal I think is what you're talking about to the ordeal.
It should not be underestimated.
I don't know if we haven't met before.
So I have a history as a static Sean that I'd done a lot of ecstatic work
around.
What does that mean?
It makes static pushing yourself hard until your reality changes.
A Mercedes Eliade that's sort of a guy who defined Shama is defined it as
ordinary realities,
but we all have.
And if you push yourself hard enough through any mechanism you can think of
eventually your reality breaks and you have other insight,
other knowledge,
other ways of understanding the world.
And so for me,
it's been things like,
you know,
dance all night long or drumming or you know,
other,
other things as well.
But the idea is to push yourself until you get out of your own way until your
monkey mind breaks down until you leave that behind.
So as a showman you would lead people and these dance marathons.
Sure.
Or just do it myself.
I mean,
I'm,
I'm a west African drummer as well,
so I'm often,
what's that mean?
It means I,
I,
I drum for dance classes.
I drum for,
you know,
people dancing all night long,
run a fire until they,
until they flop on the ground speaking in tongues.
The idea is to,
is to give yourself a chance so you can change your reality.
So you're looking at this though from the point of view of a neuroscientist and
instead of a crazy hippie,
well,
I was a crazy hippie before I was a neuroscientist.
You can't tell,
but I have about as much ink as you do.
Um,
and so I have a lot of that'd be possible when I see your forearms.
Well,
you know,
it's,
it's all,
it's all exactly what you got,
like flowers and now it's all [inaudible] truck and it's all Celtic and really?
Yeah.
Um,
but you know,
I,
I grew up as like,
uh,
on the east coast as a hard nose know east coaster.
And I did the find this world of being a,
you know,
sort of Shaman,
if you will.
I'm also a motorcyclist,
so I have a,
you know,
ride cross country and do a lot of long road trips.
But yeah,
I also put a nice dress shirt on and going,
you know,
do science too.
You walk in and out of many worlds.
Yeah.
I think it's important to do that,
to not hold any identity to rigorously.
What is your opinion of Ibogaine?
Um,
I don't know enough about it is the short answer.
Uh,
I think it's interesting.
I'm intrigued by it and I think for folks that are struggling with certain types
of drug addiction,
uh,
I have some clients who have gone through that particular thing and say that
they're,
you know,
they were impressed by it or they got something out of it.
I just don't have enough,
you know,
real clear firsthand experience to talk about it.
No amount of people that have done it,
I've never done it either.
But the amount of people that have done it that have had addiction issues and
gone through it and it's wiped out their addiction issues,
it's a pretty staggered,
but you know,
that isn't only true of Ibogaine.
That's true of things like,
um,
Moscow Iowasca,
mushrooms,
Ketamine,
um,
electric convulsive shock therapy.
Really these things.
And this is a hypothesis.
I'm,
you know,
this is a theory.
I have that all of these things act this in a similar way on the brain to reset
to cause a systemic wide sort of flip the switch.
Um,
you know,
ECT is still used for medication resistant depression.
It's one of the few things that works.
If drugs don't work for you,
depression,
ECT will lift your depression.
Um,
so we'll ketamine,
you know,
one is zapping you when is sedating you,
but I think they're really going after sort of a reset,
uh,
deep in the brain in some way.
So this transformative experience being so completely alien to normal states of
consciousness is enough to give you this new new blank slate or at least know
starting point,
or at least,
you know,
maybe it could be sort of hormetic,
it could be a stress or your body reacts to with healing.
So I'm almost anything that affects depression that lifts depression does.
So by raising neurotrophic factor in the hippocampus,
hippocampus is involved with memory formation,
also exploring the environment and there's a compound called BDNF,
brain derived neurotrophic factors,
the growth hormone or growth factor and the brain.
Anything that lifts depression raises BDNF.
BDNF is the final common pathway,
if you will,
of antidepressants.
It's not Serotonin,
dopamine,
norepinephrine,
it's not exercise.
It doesn't matter what you say,
your antidepressant drug or mechanism is how it actually works downstream is
BDNF.
That's fascinating.
I'm really glad you brought up.
Really glad you brought up the expression.
Depression.
Yeah.
Because,
um,
I don't,
I don't suffer from depression.
I've had many close friends who do and I've always been concerned or confused or
curious as to what causes it.
Is it an environmental issue?
Is it a biological issue?
Is it a combination of the two?
Yeah,
because
I've had friends whose lives were not going well.
Their career wasn't going well,
their romantic life wasn't going well,
and they were quote unquote depressed.
Then their career turned around,
the romantic life turned around and they were no longer depressed.
Yeah.
And so I've always wondered how much of this idea that we have of someone being
sick.
It's just based on the input that you're getting from your environment,
whether or not you're getting positive feedback.
If you're in love,
you'll feel great.
You know,
you're with someone you care to be with.
If you have a job that's awesome,
you get excited to go to work.
All these things are good.
You're,
you're,
you're doing well.
You don't have to worry about your bills.
You're in a rewarding relationship where you feel supported and loved.
You don't have this feeling all the time of being lonely or being left out.
How much of that is it an environmental issue?
How much of that is just your brain is lacking a certain amount of pills and how
many people are medicated because their environment is shitty.
And so instead of giving you the impetus to change and alter your environment to
benefit you,
you're instead given a pill that makes your environment tolerance.
Well,
yeah,
that's a really complex question.
Um,
there's a few things to think about.
One is things like depression or anxiety aren't always bad.
You know,
there's often a good reason to be sad or a good reason to be tense.
like if your spouse dies,
you're going to be depressed.
You know,
you have an exogenous and outside cause for your depression.
You lose your job.
You,
you know,
your bank account's empty.
There's lots of good reasons to be stressed and to have sort of negative
emotional reactions to those things.
Anxiety is the same way.
If you're being chased by a tiger,
you better be anxious.
You better run.
Um,
when someone's life becomes less stressful,
you're right.
Some people become not depressed anymore and that's,
I would consider that like a low key form of depression if,
if they just get a little bit depressed or depressed because of exogenous life
things.
Um,
the,
all the diagnosis,
a diagnostic criteria for depression suggest that you need to have all these
symptoms for many weeks occur.
I think it's two or three weeks minimum across more than one domain of your
life.
So it's not simply being sad for a few weeks because of a bad thing that
happened too.
It's what happens with how your emotional regulation gets changed by that or
turns into a problem.
So there are many people,
their lives get better.
They got a new job,
they,
you know,
have things perk up and they don't become non-depressed.
They stay depressed,
they stay maybe just an hedonic.
They can't experience joy for something for from,
from their life.
Or they experienced,
you know,
more subtle swings of mood then than full blown depression.
But depression can last even in the face of your life being awesome.
You know,
how long has it been that we've diagnosed this idea of depression?
I mean for the long time.
How long,
how many decades?
Um,
several layman's.
We were three more than that.
Yeah,
I would,
I would say that major depression amendment,
I'm not actually sure when,
when it crept into the Dsm,
the whole issue of diagnosis is a very thorny issue anyways.
The DSM was not really develop the diagnostic and statistical manual,
which is what psychologists and psychiatrists use for diagnoses was not really
developed to help with diagnoses.
It was developed to help with insurance companies.
It's Kinda like the BMI.
The Bmi for you and me would say we're overweight,
if not obese because we're pretty beefy guys,
but I'm not obese at 180 pounds.
Right.
You know,
but if I was,
if my body fat was higher,
muscle mass was lower,
I would be.
And the same thing's true with diagnoses.
It was really a tool used to figure out what to pay on insurance to some extent.
And so at a population level,
if I took a thousand people,
the BMI would,
would work pretty well for most of them.
And the same is true of the DSM.
It works pretty well at a population level.
But when you drill down to the individual,
sometimes their symptoms don't fit.
The DSM or the how long they've had symptoms for or the or the course of their
disease hasn't really totally fit.
And as a psychologist say,
oh,
you don't fit all the criteria,
therefore I can't give you a diagnosis.
No,
they pick whatever's closest since you're an insurance company can pay for their
therapy and so that you can maybe get the drugs that they want to give you.
Um,
so it's a pretty vague,
I mean the diagnoses is not as precise a field as a non psychologist might,
might think.
I love that you used the term disease cause that's what I wanted to bring up
because that's what it's,
it's referred to as depression disease.
Yeah.
Depression is a disease and you hear it all the time and I,
you hear it oftentimes in commercials that are selling drugs.
And that really concerns me because I'm like,
well,
you might be giving someone the green light to take a pill and it takes away the
power from them,
takes away the power to change your life,
to alter your life for the better because you've got this horrible scenario in
your life,
horrible situation,
circumstances,
whatever.
They're leading you to feel like shit all the time.
And someone's coming along and saying,
hey man,
you don't need to get a better job.
You know,
you're depressed.
Right.
And you know,
all those disease,
it,
I mean I think it is a disease because it's not at ease.
Is Dis ease.
You're not at ease.
Sure,
sure.
Um,
I think it can become a disease.
It can become entrenched and become stuck in that mode.
And that's when it's a big problem.
Uh,
you know,
um,
from the point of view of brain activity,
if you look at depressed brains,
if I brought it up a hundred depress brains into my clinic and did brain mapping
or Q EEG on them,
what I would find in most of them is an asymmetry in the frontal lobes.
Many people who are depressed have an overactive right frontal lobe and an
underactive left.
This bias of left side being more active than right as typical glass half empty
approach.
The world explore environments when the right is more active than the left,
he withdraw.
You shut down,
you don't want to do.
And so there is a brain signature often present in major depression of a left
right bias that goes in the opposite direction.
You know,
if you measured the Dalai Lama,
he'd be really strong.
Left biased was,
what about bullshit?
Zero part that says bullshit.
Can you find out what that is on him?
Uh,
do the,
do you think he's full of Shit?
Thank God I'm not buying the robes.
Uh Huh.
No.
Okay.
All right.
What came first,
the chicken or the egg though when it comes to this right left brain thing.
Really good point.
Yeah.
I have no idea.
I mean I've never,
you know,
track someone through being non-depressed into depressed cause they'll come and
see me once they're depressed.
So it could be a predisposition your brain in a little bit like this and you're
a little bit,
you know,
oriented towards becoming a little bit depressed and then stress sores mount,
I mean jeans are the same way.
Genes only account for about 30% of our experience and 70% of our experiences.
How the environment interacts with us.
And the same is true of anything else.
It's cognitive or psychological.
You may have a slight tendency towards a depressed brain,
you know,
right.
Front dominance.
But unless your life becomes sucky or things really build up or you feel unsafe
or unmet or on,
you know,
fed or or something else you might ever develop.
The depression patterns that really you get stuck in.
Have you ever monitored people pre and post depression or someone who has
recovered from it?
And what are the,
what are the changes that you observe?
I mean,
all the time you see the asymmetry reverse,
go back to the sort of normal or typical brain patterns.
Yeah,
it happens all the time.
We,
not every person with depression has frontal asymmetries,
but it's happens often enough that I believe it when I see it in the brain maps
as a sign.
I mean,
often new brain maps without doing clinical histories first because I don't want
to be biased.
So I'll sit you down and you know,
record some baselines.
And then after I have the date,
I'll say,
okay,
I'm seeing this pattern,
I'm seeing some frontal asymmetries,
you know,
this,
this thing here.
Uh,
the literature suggests and many people that come into my clinic have some
depression when they see this pattern.
Is that true for you?
And I usually get a,
yeah.
How'd,
you know,
um,
or anxiety.
There's patterns for,
there's patterns for Adhd or trauma,
you know,
CD or PTSD.
Um,
and so I tend to unpack what I'm looking at based on their symptoms and then
confirm,
uh,
get them to confirm what I'm guessing.
So now I want to do a brain scan.
Before I was really not interested.
I want to find out what the fuck is wrong with.
There you go.
I want to get into that.
Come down to Beverly Hills and uh,
we'll uh,
we'll hook you up.
How long does it take?
It takes under an hour.
Uh,
and if we,
and we can do a pre and post a two condition map for you.
If you wanted like a totally clean off of caffeine or you know,
something else.
Marijuana.
I have to beat around the Bush,
man.
I started looking at Frank's.
No problem.
They look a little half smile.
Yeah,
sure,
sure.
So if you want to,
you know,
come in one day without having smoked up,
get a brain map that's going to be tough and then smoke up.
Um,
we'll do another brain map and I'll show you how your brain changes.
and here's something interesting.
Uh,
the brain mapping is the assessment process.
We often do the neurofeedback with the training process.
Neurofeedback seems to reset tolerance to cannabis in a few days.
Neurofeedback,
meaning biofeedback on brainwaves,
biofeedback on brainwaves,
meaning what does that meeting a training up or down specific like making your
brain make more Beta and less feta,
which isn't an attentive focused call state.
And how would you do that?
So I would stick electrode to the top of your head and measure the amount of
let's say Theta Theta is a brainwave that when it goes up,
you're distracted,
impulsive,
checked out.
When it goes down,
you're focused and it's going to fluctuate moment to moment cause you aren't
making a static amount of this brainwave.
You're making,
you know,
the amount of your environment and your internal environment demands.
And so whenever it tends to trend down,
maybe uh,
I'll,
I'll have you play one of your podcasts and the volume swell,
the volume,
your pockets would go up whenever your state,
it goes down and everything and it goes back up.
The volume drops.
And so your brain goes,
hey wait,
I was listening to that,
you know,
interesting guy.
And over several,
you know,
over half an hour you might have several hundred of these resuming of feedback
of rewards and that can be something like an audio or a video.
It can be a spaceship flying.
It doesn't seem to matter how we reward the brain when training.
Just when we yoke the rewards to some parameter that's changing in your brain
and by just stimulating various areas on the scalp,
just measuring areas,
just measuring area.
She stimulate the stimulus,
the the,
the feedback is actually coming in your eyes and ears,
music,
video,
animations,
but then you know when your brain trends or drifts in the wrong direction,
the game stops,
the music stops,
the podcast,
audio drops,
whatever it is you're,
you're,
you're playing with on the,
on the computers and it causes your mind to want to get it back.
Your brain,
your lower level in your mind.
Yeah.
Okay.
We'll define the difference.
What's the Dif?
The mind is what you're aware of.
I would say,
and this is a more core low level,
I mean this,
this process of biofeedback was discovered in the late sixties on cats,
cats,
and a tourist Lee,
bad instruction followers,
right?
Fuckers,
So you're never going to,
this is not a cognitive process.
Cats didn't try to make,
in this case,
cat's got a dropper of milk whenever their brainwaves and up in one direction,
milk came out of a dropper and they learned over time to produce more of this
brainwave that gave them the milk dropper fascinate.
And then six months of this,
this one experiment that a Dr. Barry Sterman did in the late six days,
six months later,
he pulled a bunch of cats out of his subject pool to do a rocket fuel exposure
experiment.
NASA had said,
hey look,
our astronauts are getting really sick.
They're getting nauseous.
How dangerous is this?
You know,
hydrazine stuff we're using as rocket fuel.
Could you please expose a bunch of animals to it and see,
you know,
how much it takes to kill them or,
or,
or what the dose response curve is.
And so doctor Sterman at Ucla in the late sixties,
um,
it was exposing cats to increasing levels of rocket fuel vapors and found that
little bit,
you know,
they planted a little more,
they stumbled a little more,
they cried.
And then like seizure,
coma,
death,
this nice linear,
you know,
with increasing dose except of the cats,
he was using a certain subset,
like six of 30 or something,
refuse to have seizures.
And the whole curve of unstable brain was pushed to the right.
Couldn't figure out why until you realize,
oh,
wait a minute.
I use these same six cats in a previous experiment to increase their brainwaves
in this one brainwave that,
that I thought was a nice target to go after.
And it turns out that brainwave is the antiseizure brainwave.
When you train it up,
you have decreased dramatically decreased seizure activity in the brain.
And so he found this,
you know,
this brainwave was sort of metta stable in,
in encouraging brain activity.
And his a lab manager at the time was a medication,
uncontrolled,
epileptic,
having like tens of seizures a month,
which is basically a death sentence.
Your brain will,
you know,
Swiss cheese over time and you'll,
you'll have major,
major longterm problems.
Um,
and she demanded,
he built her a biofeedback machine to train up this brainwave.
And over the next year or two,
they did some training and after a couple of years she went off all meds.
I'm a seizure-free.
Wow,
that's crazy.
And about that time Barry Sterman funding was all pulled.
Really.
He probably,
he submitted a paper to Epilepsia the journal and suddenly his,
uh,
government funding all vanished.
So the conspiracy theorist,
uh,
you know,
ideas start to mount.
When you think about,
you know,
the late sixties and big drug companies not wanting a non drug intervention for
epilepsy out there.
Now,
what is the current protocol on this stuff today?
I mean,
how many people are using this kind of treatment with epilepsy?
I'm not sure,
actually.
I'm not an epileptologist.
I've had a few folks come through my center who do have seizures and I've
reduced them.
Um,
but,
uh,
I'm not sure of the numbers of epileptologists out there using it.
Um,
the numbers of neurofeedback providers,
I'm just as a hand waving guests.
Let's say this 10,000 in the u s and there's many more of course throughout the
world.
When I go to big conferences,
there's,
you know,
a thousand to 1500 people at the tray,
the professional trade shows for this stuff,
and it's two of them.
So you figure,
extrapolate and at least 10,000 practitioners in a,
in the u s in fact,
just down the street here in Woodland Hills,
some of the,
the,
the giants in the field,
the authors,
they sort of founded the field,
uh,
soon after Sterman made these discoveries.
The authors,
um,
uh,
at EEG info launched,
um,
sort of the field of neurofeedback for clinicians.
They built software and hardware for many years for clinicians to use.
Well,
that is unbelievable.
The idea that they would pull funding just because he's come up with something
that takes away from the money that the farms and who knows if that's actually
what happened.
But it's a good story that there's this potential,
you know,
sort of big brother,
big Pharma,
a inflection.
And this is not beyond the pale.
This is,
this is very possible.
You know,
when,
um,
when neurofeedback started getting really big,
a lot of what it was first used for his Adhd,
it's sort of the magic bullet for Adhd.
You know,
it's called the 20 hours solution for Adhd.
Um,
when,
uh,
this is starting to really be used maybe 15,
20 years ago,
um,
a couple of the big
drug companies were paying scientists to go to Chad meetings,
the,
the ADHD support group meetings and say,
nope,
neurofeedback doesn't work.
Wow.
They were being paid by the drug companies to go and,
you know,
anti Shell for,
for,
you know,
anti neurofeedback.
Well,
we find that today with marijuana and we find that today with pharmaceutical
companies paying people to talk badly and,
and,
and not just that,
but testify about the negative aspects of cannabis.
And then you find out they're being paid by pharmaceutical companies hundreds of
thousands of dollars.
Yeah.
I mean,
what,
when did money,
you get in so deep into not only medicine,
but politics?
I mean,
when you and I were kids,
this wasn't like this was it.
I don't know.
I mean,
I wasn't paying attention to as a 10 year old,
but yeah,
I don't think we're as aware or maybe it just wasn't as transparent.
We're aware of information,
you know,
being everywhere.
It wasn't really there in the 70s the way it is now.
Right.
So,
right.
Well all the Nixon studies that Nixon funded,
a bunch of the Nixon administration funded a bunch of studies trying to find the
negative aspects of cannabis and that's on sale positively not just failed,
found so many positive things they had to burry.
Yup.
Yeah.
And we're dealing with that today.
I mean,
today you still have,
uh,
there was,
there was this horrible story,
a horrible video of the,
uh,
head of the DEA having a conversation with someone in Congress where the guy is
breaking it down to where he's saying,
what is worse is cannabis as bad as math.
And she's like,
well,
they're both bad and they're both bad.
Okay.
What is w what it has a negative more negative health risks?
Is it cannabis or is it meth and she won't do it.
She won't do it because it's an ideology.
It's a,
she's got a very specific pattern of thinking and speaking that she's supposed
to engage in.
And she won't vary.
She won't deviate.
And there's not,
unfortunately not a lot of good research out there.
I mean,
I'm putting together a cannabis study with my lead tech at the alternatives and
we're just going through a literature review trying to figure out what the state
of the literature is.
And,
uh,
I'm looking at,
you know,
brain activity.
So I'm like,
my questions are things like,
well,
how long does it active in your brain and what are the brain changes that
cannabis produces?
And we're looking at studies from the 70s and some of them in the 80s and little
footnotes and methodology.
So,
okay,
the THC concentration in this study is 2% two and a half percent,
2.1%,
whatever.
And nowadays,
you know,
the stuff being delivered to your door,
uh,
from the collective is 20% 23%,
25%.
So cannabis has gotten 10 times as strong since our parents were,
you know,
well,
that's just dirt weed though.
There was a study that they did recently.
They said that they got ahold of some marijuana from the 1960s and seventies and
there the variation was between two to 5% for shitty weed but as high as 15% for
what they called Acapulco gold.
Since Emilia,
that's what the old timers used to call the good high end.
But that's what they call it.
Yeah.
Um,
but so that,
that means that the good we'd have today and the great,
we'd have them are pretty similar equipment,
but the great we'd have today is some next level shit and all the scientists and
the average,
you know,
squares in the late 60,
it didn't have access to the acapulco gold.
How did they not a scientist?
Well,
I mean all the studies were done on a low potency compared to today,
low potency weed.
So I'm not sure why they didn't have access to it,
but they're all using two,
3%.
They're probably worried about the man.
Everybody was scared of,
uh,
you know,
giving them the good weed.
Yeah,
probably they didn't know anybody.
But today you're dealing with these botanists that are going deep and there.
I've heard as many as 30 to 35%.
I've never seen that much.
I'd want that until too much.
Right here.
35.
Wow.
That's a little too much oil.
Blow your fucking head off.
No,
that's just some crazy weed that these guys have put together.
30 percent's a lot.
I might have given it to people that are from out of town and uh,
they don't function well on it.
It hits them in a very strange,
it's funny to watch.
Then you do it during your pockets.
It's kind of cruel.
I've done it.
Wow.
And not cruel.
They asked for it.
They want to see what's up.
But the,
um,
the real issue is really that.
It's just,
what do you use to,
I mean if you are used to this 34% THC,
you know,
you take one hit and you're good.
Right?
It's like alcohol.
I mean,
is alcohol,
is it,
is stronger alcohol a problem?
No,
not really.
We know that whiskey is stronger than wine,
you know,
we know that.
So you drink a large glass of wine and you're fine.
You don't drink a large glass of whiskey.
Right.
But it's harder to,
you know,
it,
it's,
it's rather,
it's easy to get into trouble with whiskey than beer.
Sure.
Because the,
the momentum has,
you know,
faster consequences.
Yes.
That's a very good point.
So I wanna is the same thing.
And I mentioned that I eliminate tolerance to marijuana in,
in the first week of training.
People's tolerance is God like just gone.
And I work with people that are often like,
yeah man,
I'm professional.
I know what I'm doing.
Shut up.
Okay,
well you know,
just be really careful.
No,
no,
no.
I'm good.
I've been smoking for 25 years.
How does this tolerance get minimized?
I'm not sure what the mechanism is.
I just know that it's a real effect cause people come back the next day like,
yeah man,
I smoked up and I stared at the ceiling all night.
I couldn't get out of the couch and I couldn't,
I was,
I was drooling during dinner.
We didn't talk to my wife.
What did you do?
To me it's like the first,
it's like give it a giant blunt to a high school kid has never seen we'd,
wow.
It's a multiple on the dose effect in some way.
Does it deal with the effects of it from eating it as well as smoking it or is
it only smoking it?
It must be.
It must be a belt.
I haven't actually rigorously examine the differences,
but it must be both.
I would wonder because the,
the,
the difference in eating it is very dramatically different cause you know,
it's processed by the liver,
you know?
Yeah.
But it's still THC.
I mean eventually the brain is still getting a similar effect.
It's actually not,
it's 11 Roxy metabolite.
When it's processed by the liver,
it's producing this new substance.
It's fine.
Really more psychoactive than THC.
I know it lasts a lot longer.
I don't,
I don't really enjoy eating it.
It's not just last longer.
It's a totally different drug.
Your liver produces this,
this metabolite 11 hydroxy metabolite and it's so much more potent,
which is why when people eat cookies,
they always think they're dying.
Right now he's thinking like,
oh my God,
somebody dosed it.
I give you,
I'm sure you've probably heard of this.
There's a hilarious nine one one call or these cops had stolen weed from these
kids and made brownies with it and then they eat the brownies and they call nine
one one and they're like,
Time's going by really slow.
I think we're dead.
You never heard it?
No,
it's hilarious.
Oh my God.
That's funny.
You should pull it up Jamie.
Cause it's,
everyone should hear this cause it's so fucking stupid.
It just shows you that cops are just people.
And the idea that you could give these people is this three,
nine one one call that why no charges have been filed against the police officer
who admits to confiscating marijuana from suspects and then baking it in
brownies.
I was,
he and his wife were full and high.
They thought they had overdosed and called nine one one person.
This,
I think I'm having an overdose,
my wife over and off of what?
Marijuana.
I don't know if they had pumpkin in it.
Hey police can rescue you guys have fever.
No,
I'm good.
I think we're dying.
Oh,
how much you guys have?
I Dunno.
We made brownies and I think what that time is going by really,
really,
really glow.
Yeah.
Not responsible use right there.
I will listen to that to the day I die.
A fucking dummy.
Oh.
Oh well that's the problem with eating it.
Most people aren't aware of me.
Even you are not aware of eating it.
This,
it's a process called a one pass.
When it goes through your liver,
your first pass metabolism blows your brain out the back of your head.
Now you know,
one of the,
uh,
one of the tricks to bring somebody down who's over in Tallinn Ibuprofen.
Really?
Yeah.
Ibuprofen seems to take the edge off of weed.
So to nootropics.
Uh,
but Ibuprofen specifically seems to reduce the memory impairments you get when
you smoke.
That's fascinating.
The memory and for the short term memory impairment and potentially long term
learning memory as well.
What about the actual feeling of being high?
Does it,
it can mitigate just a tiny bit,
can take the edge off.
Like,
I've had friends that have,
you know,
oh my God,
I'm dying.
I've,
you know,
done too much.
I eaten three cookies or whatever.
Well,
here's my profit in 20 minutes later.
Okay,
thank you.
And what do you give him?
Like 800 milligrams.
Get like 400 and 400.
Yeah.
And I hear there's a new trend in a college students studying with 200
milligrams of Ibuprofen and a bong hit.
Whoa.
Because fucking they don't affect the memory formation.
I'm glad you brought that up.
Cause a big problem in college today is Adderall or,
oh my God.
Huge problem.
Huge.
What's going on with that?
Because that seems to me,
I've never done Adderall,
but from the people that I've talked to that have and understand it,
it's a stimulant.
Like very close to amphetamines,
very close to math.
Very close to my,
yeah,
a much lower dose and slightly different molecule,
but,
but very,
very close to um,
uh,
you know,
strict class trip stimulant,
a good friend,
the late great Robert Schimmel,
who was a hilarious standup comedian and a great guy.
He had a bunch of,
uh,
health issues himself and,
um,
uh,
he accidentally took Adderall once and,
he had taken the wrong medication.
I don't know whose it was or I don't,
I'm,
I don't remember the story,
but I remember he called his doctor up and he said,
hey,
I took this Adderall,
like,
am I fucked?
Because he had heart issues and uh,
the doctor said,
no,
you're going to be fine.
Just,
uh,
just ride it out.
You're going to be fine.
But you know,
obviously don't take it again.
But,
uh,
if anything goes horribly wrong,
call me but I think you're going to be fine.
And he said he just cleaned his house and organized his notes,
said he took all of his comedy notes and just went over them.
He said,
I couldn't believe how organized I was.
He was so motivated to get things done and that,
and that pushes stimulants does happen.
This is why students abused it.
But that push doesn't continue if you take it every day.
Okay.
Right.
So it's like you're chasing the dragon.
It has a business and the euphoria,
I mean your,
your friend had some euphoria probably from the two that goes away as soon as
you used to the drug.
Well he wasn't interested in doing it again.
He just accidentally did it.
But he was like,
God I got so much work done and I've,
I've heard that before.
Like my friend Eddie,
my friend Eddie problem with dated a few gals who had problems with stimulants
and uh,
he said he would always tell cause you go over their house,
it'd be fucking spotless was like those checks would always be cleaning their,
it was Marco.
They would just constantly be cleaning up.
What is it about stimulants that make you want to get things done?
Well,
dopamine is the primary neurotransmitter boosted by stimulants and dopamine is
the reward signal.
It's the salient.
This is interesting.
This is motivating.
So you get a motivation,
you know,
you find even boring tasks.
Interesting.
Wow.
So you would want to do things like clean your house because you want to do
something cause you wanna engage with your environment.
You gotta explore,
reshuffle,
play around with your environment.
Now for kids,
this chasing the dragon thing with college has got to be a giant issue though,
right?
You're popping these pills and at first it's benefiting you and then slowly that
starts to wear out.
So you're taking more.
And a lot of kids aren't ADHD don't dramatically.
And they're taking stimulants off label other people's,
you know,
black market prescriptions.
Um,
and you know,
there are some consequences to psychostimulants.
There are some negative consequences if you're not managing them in the absolute
right way.
You should,
including things like cardiovascular side effects and habit formation and
appetite suppression.
And you know,
all these things can cause major issues.
For me,
college students are some of the least healthy people anyways.
They're sleep deprived,
they eat like crap.
They don't know how to like live their lives as adults yet,
but they have no structure that their parents used to give them.
Um,
and so with all of these problems,
you throw a stimulant into the mix and they find they can be super productive on
it.
And you find kids that are now drug seeking or you know,
trying to get diagnoses,
they can get drugs.
You know,
we had this,
a young
Gal who was an intern on fear factor back in the day and she was very nice and
you would never think of her as being someone that had a problem with the drugs.
But boy you bring up aderall round her and like,
yeah,
her eyes would light up like she had like two like white stars for pupils and
she'd be like,
who has that Ross?
The cocaine response.
Right.
Oh,
that's like,
okay.
You know,
that's,
that's the,
it's the,
it's the reward.
It's the dopamine hit.
Makes you go,
yes,
that's the most interesting thing I've ever heard of.
You know,
I was watching her and this guy,
this other guy who used to work there and they had this conversation and he's
like,
yeah,
well,
you know,
I would just take Adderall.
And she was like,
you've got to have the wrong,
you have Adderall.
Like,
and it was weird.
It was like you were watching someone like Trenton's.
It's like Gollum in the ring.
Yeah.
They call patches.
Dopaminergic drugs are,
in my opinion,
some of the most dangerous things we have because they,
they hijack learning because they really get in the way.
And so it's not just that it's pleasurable and that's reinforcing,
it's the pleasurable and dopamine gets boosted to super physiological levels.
Well,
how ironic that it hijacks learning when you're using it to help learn.
Yeah.
But you're not really learning,
right?
You're just studying.
Yeah.
Um,
some of the psycho stimulants do seem to improve learning.
I think Ritalin is in that class,
but real,
a very atypical psychostimulant a methylphenidate.
It's not a typical like Adderall or something and it,
it,
it actually improves games.
Seems to improve longterm potentiation or at least at least,
uh,
affected in some way that is not negative.
What about provigil and Nuvigil?
Those are other dramas.
Huge.
I hate them.
Really?
Yeah.
I,
uh,
I took modafinil provigil myself off label for attention,
and just about died from it.
Whoa.
Ended up in the hospital,
head to toe hives,
lungs closing up.
Whoa.
I've never heard that.
We had a massive systemic reaction to it.
And,
um,
people that have attention problems and I grew up,
you know,
Adhd,
people that have attention problems have dramatically increased side effects
from that class of drugs.
Provigil and Nuvigil a Daffodil Arba Daffodil.
I've taken that stuff and nothing,
nothing's happened to me at all.
But I,
I,
I'd take 150 milligrams.
I took a hundred a hundred every morning for two weeks.
Well,
it's prescribed to take every day.
I mean,
when you're prescribed,
take it every day,
that's how it's supposed to be.
Oh,
so you were giving them prescription prescription as opposed to just an x?
No,
I mean it was an experiment because I didn't like psychostimulants and I said,
how long ago was this?
This is,
uh,
just before I launched true brain,
which was one of the reasons I did it.
So like two and a half years ago.
Um,
and I ended up,
you know,
in the Er,
a UCLA,
literally head to toe hives.
I couldn't,
I was miserable for about three and a half weeks.
Whoa.
What they said.
Eventually it was,
it was something called Erythema multiforme minor.
And there a major form that's called Steven Johnson Syndrome and that's where
your skin peels off.
Whoa dude.
So I,
you know,
I luckily didn't have that major version,
but I was still incredibly miserable in my lungs,
were you know,
having major issues.
So I,
I,
I just about died from it.
[inaudible] I've heard many people that are terrified of that stuff,
but they couldn't figure out a reason why.
And Yours is the first real legitimate boosts brain,
histamine.
And histamine is,
I call it a master neurotransmitter and all the other neurotransmitters can be
modulated by it.
So you raise Histamine,
you raise dopamine system and raise serotonin.
Um,
and for me,
the histamine and the brain has to caused a body histamine over sensitization or
reaction or something.
Wow.
So,
and this is not uncommon if you look at the old,
like some of the review papers,
I'm Anafranil you find that all of the studies on people with Adhd have
incredibly dramatically increased side effects compared to non ADHD people.
So you shouldn't use,
you know,
but after all is great.
If you're asleep,
you know,
a,
a narcoleptic person or somebody who's doing,
you know,
sleep,
wake shift disorders or things.
But unless you absolutely need it to modify your sleep,
it's not great for attention.
I mean,
I,
I got some mild attention benefits from it the first couple of weeks.
It's just nothing compared to psychostimulants.
It's nothing compared to neurofeedback or even like meditation.
Mindfulness can change your brain and shore up attention resources.
I want to get to mindfulness in a moment,
but what,
what is the difference between new vigil and provigils?
Yeah,
so Modafinil,
the,
the first product is provigils.
The is the brand name,
um,
is a,
is a mix of left and right hand molecules.
Um,
when you're making a organic chemistry,
things are sort of naturally developed instead of to mirror image molecules in
most chemical synthesis.
And so there's an l and an our form of the [inaudible] in the,
in there mixed in the modafinil product in the,
in the arm Modafinil,
which is new vigil.
It's only one half.
It's the,
it's the right hand molecule.
They are.
Um,
and so the,
our molecule a threat ugly,
you know,
typically in,
in north,
in brain chemistry,
one of the molecules is psychoactive and one of them is much,
much less so and or causes side effects.
So a lot of the modern drugs we'll use an an l or an all forum only and get rid
of other half of the molecule.
Um,
Modafinil,
both the owl and the are a version of the molecule are psychoactive.
The r form is a little more psychoactive and tends to have a more stimulant type
feeling.
So I'm subjectively,
I've taken both subjectively.
Modafinil is,
you know,
interesting and has this sort of bi modal peak where you get one hump six hours
in another hump,
but 12 hours in a Arbonne FNL has the same sort of sick 12 to 16 hour window of
activity.
But it's only one peak of activity.
It's cause the only one molecule.
So in regular anafranil you're,
you're metabolizing two different substances,
if you will.
And having slightly different effects from them and the arm and Afa nails only
one half of the molecule of the mix of molecules you would get.
I've only tried new vigil,
I haven't tried to pro vigil,
but I've,
I've done it many times when I'm tired,
so,
so new.
So pro vigil will be a little bit less stimulating and you might have some
additional effects that are not new vigil or pro vigil.
Pro Pro is the mix of Lnr Nuvigil uh,
the,
the generic name for new vigil,
his arm and Afa?
No.
Okay.
You know,
Ar Modafinil,
but it's the letter r you can think of it that way for the right hand molecule
so that,
that's the more discreet,
theoretically if you were side effects,
it's a bit stronger.
In some ways.
I'm more of a stimulant effect where we're proper provigil or Modafinil is the,
is the racemic mix of the left and right hand molecules.
And when you started having your side effects,
was this an accumulative effect?
Did you
right away the no,
no,
no.
It took about 12,
13 days in before I had,
like I woke up,
uh,
my hands were kind of puffy and itchy and by the end of that day there was like
deep,
deep soreness and a lot of parts of my body.
And um,
like the Bob is my feet and my palms were like sensitive and itchy.
Whoa.
And I didn't take any more.
And the next day I woke up like with a pressure or Urticaria carrier,
massive hives.
So you knew that it was most likely related to that?
Well,
I have no allergies to any medications.
I've never experienced anything else like that.
I've never had hives in my life.
I'm not someone who gets,
you know,
hay fever.
Um,
so I had no idea.
But the only thing I've added into my,
uh,
sort of regimen at the same time,
at the end of this two weeks,
I also got the flu and it's Po,
it's likely that the immune,
you know,
sort of surge of getting the flu interacted in some way with a histamine surge
from the pro vigil and the two things together,
we're sort of a perfect storm of my body hating himself,
you know?
Wow.
But I am not a fan and I also think that the,
the gains,
the possible gains,
attention,
cognition,
focus from modafinil are,
are minor.
Not that dramatic.
I mean,
uh,
Coleen forms alpha GPC a much stronger support to cognition than Modafinil is.
Well,
I found that to be the case.
I've found Coleen to be much better as far as memory retention and execution and
things along those lines.
But as far as,
uh,
being awake,
yeah.
Less wakeful promoting wakefulness and cognition are not necessarily the same
thing.
Yes,
I agree.
Um,
so you know,
wakefulness,
if that's your issue because of narcolepsy,
because you're working night shift,
there may be a reason,
you know,
you're up,
you're a jet fly,
a jet fighter or an airline pilot,
you know,
commercial airline pilot.
We were up for many hours,
you know,
having to remain on.
Sure.
There's,
there's a reason it might make sense,
but not if you're a bio hacker.
Just trying to get a little more out of your schoolwork or more out of your,
you know,
high powered business day.
I don't think there's really any benefit or any good reason to take them at
Avondale compared to what else is out there.
I know a dude who's taken it every day for like eight,
nine years and he was wacky as fuck and I think that might've had something to
do with it.
Maybe just end.
I got chicken and then,
you know,
yeah.
Not being forthcoming about taking it either.
It's one of those weird things you wanted to kind of keep on the DL.
Hmm.
Tim Ferriss who wrote a book,
the four hour body.
Tim,
he didn't want to talk about it in his book because he was worried that people
would start taking it like candy and they,
and they are to some extent in some questions.
Silicon Valley Valley.
Yeah,
I was just going to bring that up.
Let me know.
And Dave Asprey,
he talks about,
you know what daffodils and they're all very pro modafinil.
I think I'm the only guy out there in the biohacking spaces like this stuff is,
saw it.
The stuff is,
is,
is minimally effective.
It's dangerous.
And unless you're a narcoleptic,
it's just not for you.
Well,
coincidentally,
you're the only one qualified to actually discuss the real mechanisms of the
compounds in the way you affect your brain.
Yeah,
I mean,
and,
and we don't know what Modafinil really does to the brain.
There's some theories.
We think it boosts brain histamine.
We think it Sorta flushes the rx system in the hypothalamus to make you wakeful.
But that's all still theory.
What about this shit?
Cannabis?
No,
this is in Canada.
What does,
this is tobacco.
This is one of these wacky vape pipes thing that the kids are smoking.
They see these things.
Interesting.
It's a vaporizer for tobacco.
Yeah.
Everybody's smoking tobacco out of these wacky fan.
I'm not a fan of tobacco.
I was a cigarette smoker for a few years.
You were?
Yeah,
maybe like five years or six years.
How long ago was this?
Um,
I probably quit about a 12 or 13 years ago.
so I think I smoked from like,
you know,
college and then a few years after the nicotine though nicotine as a drug,
it does have some sort of a benefit or some sort of a promotion of cognitive
function.
It's glutamate receptors.
It's,
it affects learning in some ways.
We think a Sri Seal Coleen receptors,
um,
uh,
we think it's absolutely a effecting learning in some way.
Um,
but nicotine of course is fairly addictive and nicotine is also carcinogenic all
by itself,
all by itself.
Even though it's,
it has so much better.
Yeah.
Much less salt,
carcinogenic than like tobacco,
tobacco,
but nicotine even by itself.
How some carcinogenic properties,
but you see the carcinogenic effects or the,
the,
the people that have,
uh,
an issue with cigarette smoking,
it's far more likely to cause cancer that it is people that are using like say
like cigars most because they aren't getting the dosages.
Yeah.
That what it is.
People that have that use cigars are much more likely to have oral cancers.
People that smoke have lung cancers,
but it would have the numbers on cigar smoking.
Cause what I understand with what I've read is it's fairly uncommon for people
who are regular cigar smokers to get mouth cancer.
Like you might have to be one of those wacky George Burns type characters.
He's always carrying one around.
Yeah.
I'm not sure.
I mean I think you're right.
I just think that as a class,
like,
you know,
what's,
what's the benefit is minimum.
Again,
some,
uh,
some benefits to learning and cognition.
But you can get those same benefits by getting a good night's sleep really,
or by,
you know,
meditating.
Um,
so friends that are writers that are cigarette smokers and they say there's
nothing like it.
Like Tony Hinchcliffe it,
he just can't get off the cigarettes when he's writing.
Like he wrote for the Justin Bieber roast recently and he said when he's in a
writer's room and he starts firing up the cigarettes,
the idea is just start flowing.
Sure.
And you know,
is that state dependent learning?
Cause that's when he always writes.
It could be.
Right.
I'm also,
you know,
the sank we said for alcohol.
How many,
how many writers would say alcohol?
Is there muse?
A lot.
I mean this is all like,
like the,
the,
the Steinbeck disease,
right?
Anyway,
yeah.
Hemingway,
this is,
this is really,
I mean,
and is it true?
I don't know.
Yes,
you can get yourself out of your own way.
You can get some,
you know,
some,
some chemical support and start being creative.
But is it really helping you to be generative and new ideas or is it just
helping you not be stressed or is it simply that you've associated being
creative with drinking?
Well,
I know marijuana,
there's no doubt about it.
It's a little bit different.
Yeah.
That's giving you some ideas that just don't exist other than in the marijuana
state and they might not be good ideas.
Yeah,
like they are,
but when you're so they sound great when you're,
oh my God,
I just discovered everything and then later on you're like,
what the hell was I thinking?
That doesn't,
is that all?
I thought,
well that's not as exciting as I thought.
It's also he tried to like read what you wrote down and you're like,
I used to have a joke about it.
How does it go?
Then I wrote down,
actually wrote this down,
the Unicorns,
a donkey from the future.
I wrote that down on paper.
I'm like,
what the fuck is wrong with me?
Like just shows you like,
that doesn't make any sense.
But when I was high,
I was like,
this is a whole area.
If your audience was high,
even if there were a high,
they'd be like,
um,
what a unicorn is a donkey from the future.
It doesn't make any sense.
I'm not really,
yeah,
it's ridiculous.
But there's something that happens when you do smoke marijuana that does excite
the creative aspect of,
of consciousness.
Sure.
Whatever that is,
whatever that is.
And you know,
we'd have get our bad,
we didn't get,
don't know everything cannabis is doing.
It's not simply one doesn't say THC or the 11 form from,
you know,
liver format.
There's like 700 different psychoactive compounds and the burning plant.
Right.
And they did,
they differ depending on the strain dramatically.
Sometimes.
I mean,
sativa and indigo are not the same play it,
you know.
Yeah.
They came from very different sort of,
you know,
genetic trees,
if you will.
Sure.
One being the of the South American variety of one being one of an intensely
tropical climates.
Yeah.
And they have sewing so they have different benefits and you know,
so,
uh,
I mean,
I don't think we yet know,
and I'm kind of excited by what's happening with the medical and recreational
cannabis in this country because we're finally doing some of the research.
We're finding,
looking into constituent components,
all the other cannabinoids to be on THC.
Um,
we're starting to examine the endo cannabinoid and we have a cannabinoid system
built in.
Um,
there's a neurotransmitter called a Nanda.
You know,
the Sanskrit word for bliss that hits our endocannabinoid systems and
[inaudible] that's what the [inaudible] does.
Yeah,
yeah,
that's fascinating.
And we have a,
you know,
we found the car,
we found the receptor in the body before we found the,
um,
the ligature,
the binding compound in the body.
But we knew that this thing in this receptor in the body existed and cannabis
bound to it.
And so this receptor that was,
this developed from the,
the,
the human body growing up or evolving with the use of this,
this plant is that,
that's just inherently part of our system.
I think it's inherently part of our system.
I mean,
you know,
evolution is tension tends to reinvent the same thing and tended to conserve
biological constructs,
molecules,
Oregon systems across species.
So like,
you know,
a mouse has a heart,
so does a human.
They also have,
uh,
endogenous cannabinoid systems.
Um,
I think we have to at least two categories of cannabinoid systems.
One is immune and one is bliss.
And we know a,
an exogenous,
a,
a plant that affects the blitz system,
you know,
cannabis,
um,
economic area affects the other cannabinoid system.
I as a,
an herb that boosts your immune system and is it really worked to boost your
immune system?
I think it does.
Yeah.
I mean,
I certainly have taken it.
If you take it when you're just starting to get sick,
it can shut down and illness in my experience.
Really?
Yeah.
And always wondered whether or not that was legit.
I think it is.
I don't think it's as dramatic as,
you know,
a biotics or anything.
Um,
but I do think there's some,
there's something there,
but you know,
this,
this plant,
this purple coneflower I can,
Aisha plant is a cannabinoid.
Uh,
you know,
it affects your Canab annoyed system.
That's how it affects your immune system.
That's amazing.
Uh,
what about CBDS,
CBDS and relationship to cancer,
which is something that is being researched quite a bit lately.
Yeah.
I am not up on all the research,
some of the first papers or the past couple of decades where all CBD,
CBD,
you know,
reducing inflammation,
reducing cancer,
killing cancer cells.
I've seen a few papers recently that say the non CBD compounds also do that and
do it better.
Wow.
Nanci like THC has,
has anticancer properties and do it better than CBD.
It May.
Yeah.
CBDS being good for inflammation,
joint pain,
things along those lines.
The paper I read had THC also working on all those other aspects as well.
Wow.
So the isolation of the CBD might just be because people were trying to avoid
THC.
Try to avoid the psychoactive.
Yeah.
Cause CBD,
um,
the ratio active,
it's non psychoactive.
In fact,
the ratio of CBD to THC effects the House psychoactive something is so too much
CBD and you aren't gonna get high off your pot even in the presence of THC and
counteracting counteract each other.
Exactly.
So in inbuilt check,
is it frustrating to that all this stuff which probably could have been figured
out a long time ago were legal?
Yeah.
I mean,
it's a little frustrating,
but I look at,
you know,
if you go back a hundred years ago,
technology was nowhere compared to where it is right now.
I sort of see us on the exponential curve,
the hockey stick of acceleration now.
So would it have been nice if 50 years ago we were getting into this stuff?
Sure.
But it doesn't on a,
on a,
on a global timescale doesn't really bother me that it's happening now versus
last decade.
No.
Well,
it doesn't bother me that it's happening now and what bothers me is the
suppression that exists then they used to exist the same suppression that caused
this,
this reluctance of pharmaceutical companies to accept this treatment of epilepsy
that didn't involve drugs that they sell.
The initial anti cannabis movement was a textiles.
It's country,
right?
It was textiles and paper actually.
Yeah.
They didn't want the flax or the,
the,
the fiber's coming in and supplanting the cotton industry and the fuel
industries and things.
It was directly connected to the production and creation of a machine called the
decorticator.
Decorticator.
Yeah.
The decorticator was the first time that they developed a system of processing
hemp fire that didn't involve slavery or hard manual labor.
The reason why cotton took such a foothold is because they came up with the
cotton gin,
Eli Whitney and came up with the cotton gin.
Cotton,
uh,
became much more viable than cannabis.
Then hemp fibers of hemp are far stronger,
far superior for the paper and cloth.
It's just way tougher.
Absolutely.
Like 10 times.
And is,
or something in this canvas comes from the word cannabis.
Cannabis was originally a hemp product.
Oh,
interesting.
I knew I didn't are more far more durable,
far more durable for pants.
The original Levis are made out of canvas.
It was all cannabis.
Interesting.
Yeah.
It's all hemp based until that motherfucker that they made that book or they
made the movie reefer madness.
No,
it wasn't that.
It was,
uh,
it was a William Randolph Hearst,
Orson Welles movie citizen Kane.
That was all about this one asshole.
Right.
William Randolph Hearst owned Hearst enterprises.
He owned,
you know,
all the newspapers he owned.
I mean,
he just had this massive stranglehold on information.
Yeah.
And he was a motherfucker and this guy came out with the idea of,
first of all,
they've got in cahoots with Harry Anslinger and uh,
they,
they decided to call it marijuana,
which wasn't a name for it before marijuana was the name for a wild Mexican
tobacco plant.
That wasn't even,
it wasn't even cannabis.
So when Congress was outlawing marijuana,
they didn't exactly understand that they were outlawing hemp as a textile and as
a commodity.
Interesting.
So then you had to get like a tax stamp in order to grow hemp and then,
you know,
they needed it for World War II.
So they started this campaign,
hemp for victory and hemp for victory was this famous video that they,
uh,
that Jack,
hair,
who was a famous famous marijuana activist,
found this video to sort of sort of establish what he had been saying all along.
Like,
look,
this is something that we had grown and used as a culture for thousands of
years.
Human beings,
it's,
it was a huge part.
I mean it was what George W are,
George Herbert Walker Bush.
That was what his parachute was made of when he parachuted to safety in World
War II.
It was what the sales that Columbus sailed on was made out of.
They were all made out of hemp.
Yup.
Okay.
Yeah.
All of it.
Rope.
And when they decided to demonize it,
the way they did it was to go after racism.
They said this marijuana plant I was making blacks and Mexicans rape white
women.
Right.
Everybody went fucking crazy.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
fear,
uncertainty and doubt and marketing has even sort of,
you know,
a big player back then and nowadays you can,
it's hard to get good information about anything without,
you know,
a decent degree to understand what the noise,
where the noises shoring from.
But it's,
in a lot of ways it's very similar to what you're saying about taking away this
non drug option of treating epilepsy.
Yeah.
It's like they realize,
okay,
there's money to be made with this one solution,
this new solution.
There's no money to be made.
Let's attack it.
Yeah.
That's what they did.
I mean there's,
there's people making CBD or CBN only strains of cannabis purely for epileptic
epileptics.
Now that they suppress seizures.
I mean,
you don't want to give a five year old kid a joint,
you know,
they're already pretty stoned as a five year old.
Right.
But CBN or CBD can suppress,
uh,
epileptic activity.
You know,
where is,
I mean that's a charged issue of giving a kid cannabis,
but,
uh,
I don't see any ethical or are problematic,
you know,
use even with children if you're using it as an antiepileptic epileptic
intervention.
Well,
I have direct experience with a very good friend of mine who has a child who has
extreme epileptic seizures.
He gives,
he gives a kid medical cannabis now he moved to a state where it's legal and
moved to Washington state and he gives his kid a very small amount every day and
there's no law,
no longer any seizures.
His kid was having multiple seizures a day.
He was more,
he's also got,
he's on the autism spectrum.
It's also got like some pretty severe social issues,
which were mitigated substantially once he started.
Okay.
Interesting.
But there's all sorts of other connections to gut bacteria and there's a bunch
of inflammation issues,
diet and things that change that for,
for kids who suffer from these things,
if they don't feel totally,
truly understand and we may never,
cause I mean every individual little bit different too.
I mean it's what autism specifically is not really one thing.
It's more like the autism.
Um,
the only thing consistent across them as the social deficits.
But you can have a high functioning asbergers individual with you know,
superior cognitive skills,
incredible abilities,
but still some deficits in other areas.
And it's so they're so concerned with opening up the doorway to this stuff that
even non-psychoactive versions of these plants are illegal.
Right?
Like hemp is when we have a huge issue with that at on it.
My supplement company,
because we sell protein,
hemp protein is very bioavailable,
but we have to get it from Canada.
Right?
Cause we can't you,
you can,
you sort of can grow with the states in that law.
Just change like last week then you can now start growing commercial hemp sorta.
You wouldn't know more sort of has,
it sort of has,
but it's got a lot of resistance.
It's got a raise,
a lot of resistance in terms of how it's going to react or how the federal
government is going to react to it.
If a Republican gets in office in 2016 that's also one of the things about
medical marijuana,
like the,
they've recently soften their stance considerably on medical marijuana,
but all it takes is like one thing,
one Jeb Bush motherfucker to get into office and things can get really weird.
But as of right now,
we have to get our stuff from Canada interest.
We would love to buy it from America,
from America farmers and,
but also it's just should be something that people could,
it's,
it's a plant,
it's ridic.
It does not killing anybody and it's a plan.
It should be really that simple.
Whereas he tell anybody,
no.
Is it 20 people in the slaves?
Bren was invented today.
If Astro was about to today,
aspirin will be a scheduled substance.
That's a controlled substance.
It probably would.
Right?
It has side effects.
It can kill you.
Sure.
Yeah.
And not only that,
there's a lot of medications that they prescribed,
especially for people that have heart disease or aspirin.
Can just know that shit right in the bud.
Aspirin is an amazing,
amazing anti-inflammatory.
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
I think it's at least initially for the natural,
uh,
you know,
willow bark.
Yeah.
Can you,
can you get it in a natural form still?
Is it available?
Can you got in the forest and you know,
the inner bark of a white willow tree,
that's all it is to it.
And then you'll get a seat.
A Cila salic acid.
Yeah.
Wow.
And how will you know how much barked at shoe?
Um,
I don't think the dosages are an issue when it,
you know,
I think you'll absorb it and get pain relief or whatever.
So it's only when you swallow it,
but it becomes an issue.
No,
I think it's,
it's being absorbed through the Mucosa,
but I don't think you're going to get concentrated doses the way doing tablets
of aspirin.
Yeah,
that's what I mean.
So you can overdose on the tablets.
You can't overdose on chewing the bark.
You probably can,
but you'd have to be an asshole asshole.
And it probably tastes like ass.
I mean it's the,
these are very bitter substances.
So how did it,
everybody ever find out that that gives you a relief from a headache?
I don't know.
Probably some,
you know,
drew it,
bring it in tea or something,
you know,
a couple of years ago.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's an interesting thing that that's been around for so long and there's so,
and it's sort of like very subtly swept under the rug.
The health benefits of aspirin.
Sure,
sure.
Well,
you know,
in,
at least in the cardiac medicine,
there's still this focus of giving people the heart risks,
uh,
or heart cardiac risk of heart attack,
you know,
prophylactic doses of aspirin every day to reduce the strain on the blood
system.
And well,
I've also heard people say that after you get to a certain age,
you should just take aspirin any day every day anyway just to mitigate the
natural reaction that your body has to inflammation or,
or the,
or the clotting.
It's really not clotting.
Um,
and I think,
you know,
tam is a better drug for that long term that aspirin because it has other
benefits.
That's interesting.
I wanted to bring those up to different nootropics like Prasad,
Tim,
the different racetams.
What are your favorite ones when it comes to nootropics and
what,
what causes you to prefer those?
Well,
you know,
I'm a,
I'm the one of the scientists that true brain,
so I help in true brain is that you have it right here?
It's a yeah,
we'd be about to send you a tropic drink.
Yeah,
we have drinks and capsule form.
Uh,
and the drinks,
um,
sort of are the first to market.
Little little mini drinks.
Uh,
so you got three different colors here.
Three different colors,
blue and orange.
Why,
why is it that,
well,
once caffeinated,
which one it should say on it?
It's the blue or the green.
You don't know.
I forget.
This is your shit man.
I know.
Well we,
we,
we keep iterating and changing it.
So this is the,
this is the latest flavor we've ever come up with.
Okay.
This is caffeine free.
The blue one.
The green one's caffeinated then.
Okay.
And the orange one is the boost.
So the blue and the green ones are paroxetine based with CDP.
Coleen.
This is the original.
Yup.
Greens,
the Greens.
The caffeinated one has 80 milligrams of caffeine,
not a huge amount.
And then the orange one is oxy Rasta.
Tam based 80 milligrams is not a lot.
No,
that's like a cup of coffee though.
Um,
it's like a four ounce cup of coffee of drip coffee.
Isn't that though,
but like aren't we considering that because of like how jacked up Starbucks is
because Starbucks is a,
venti is 200 milligrams of caffeine more than that,
isn't it?
Late?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Caffeine somewhere between 75 and 150 milligrams,
um,
for every eight ounces of drip or one espresso shot.
So it takes three espresso shots to equal the amount of caffeine in a 12 ounce
drip coffee.
That's a lot of people think that espresso is much stronger and the darker you
rose,
the less caffeine you have in the bean.
Right?
So that's another thing that's a misconception,
right?
People Think,
oh,
give me the dark roast.
Want to get fucked up?
No,
a French toast is like up to a third less caffeine than a light roast.
What do you got there,
Jamie?
450 milligrams from a 20 from a,
is that Starbucks?
Yeah.
Was that by Dean one 81 80 is a short,
that's what I was thinking of.
So between as short a tall,
tall,
tall is their middle right.
And then grow.
I fucking hate all these foreign words.
God dammit.
Don't call it a grand day.
Caught a medium.
Well there's,
there's lots of reasons to boycott these guys.
Now they just went after the state of Vermont.
Uh,
Starbucks and Monsanto joined together to file suit against Vermont for
mandating labeling of Gmos.
What?
Starbucks and Monsanto?
They have GMO coffee.
No,
they just wanted,
they don't want to be mandated to label one of them.
Well if there's an issue,
is there an issue with Gmos with that?
There's an immediate d modification knee jerk.
Yeah.
When people don't understand that every fucking tomato you buy at grocery
stores,
genetic grandma's,
no such thing as a non GMO cow.
There's no such thing as a non GMO ear of corn.
If you're eating ears of corn.
That shit has been modified.
Corn has been heavily modified.
We recently in the past 10 20 years,
but we've been GMO in cattle with selective reading for thousands of years.
Right.
But isn't there a difference between selective breeding and splicing in native
genetics,
which they have done to increase the probably a difference resistance to certain
pesticides.
Roundup freaks people out at least so.
Right,
totally.
Yeah,
absolutely.
This isn't one of those things where there's not an either or.
There's there's,
there's benefits to genetically modify things to our advantage,
but there's also cost greed and,
and also when people don't want to address the actual real health concerns of
their creations,
and that's what people were worried about.
That's why when Brazil as a country filed suit against Monsanto one,
yeah,
I mean farmers,
Brazilian farmers to join together and file this gigantic suit within.
There's an Indian farmers that they have this huge issue where they,
they,
they get leased out these seeds and then they,
they're in debt and they wound up committing suicide.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I heard that article recently.
God,
it's,
it's staggering.
If you let the old sharecropping model where you,
you know,
rent the land,
sell the sea and sell the tools and you know,
now you must work for me for the next 60 years to make back your money.
Yeah.
And Monsanto is the one who's profiting off of it and just assessed just to,
what's this Monsanto Latte tell Starbucks to serve only organic non GMO milk.
True.
Starbucks is a member of the Grocery Manufacturers Association with challenging
Vermont over GMO labeling requirements.
False.
Starbucks has joined forces with Monsanto.
Ty was fooled.
How dare you know I was full air.
You Dr. Hill of dare.
You're one of those guys.
I just want to say shit.
You find Starbucks is not a part of Monsanto's GMO lawsuit.
This is from Starbucks or stop food labeling.
All right,
well now we know that was from 2014 sir.
How dare you.
I read an article recently that seem legit,
so was it in the onion?
No,
no,
no.
It seemed legit.
It was written in English,
right?
It was on the Internet.
The Fox walks.
That's the bar for some people.
Yeah.
Some people,
well there's a lot of demean.
There's websites now that we'll just write stories.
They don't even pretend that they're writing something that isn't like,
it's not even funny.
Like it's the,
they don't try to make it seem like a parody.
They just,
it's just there to,
to light a fire.
Well,
they just,
it's clickbait.
Clickbait is a huge issue across the board.
It's a huge issue with sites even than I agree with.
There's a lot of progressive sites that do it.
They write these really inflammatory titles and then you read it like,
I can't stand the,
you know,
and,
and you'll believe what happened next.
It's like,
no,
I'm not even go there now.
Just leave me alone.
One of them was about peanut butter and Jelly being racist and I was like,
cut the foot.
The fuck is this.
And so of course everybody's tweeting it and retweet it.
And if you actually read into it,
it's like,
I think some editor just jazzed up this idea of three meals a day and peanut
butter and Jelly and you know,
and w w where this,
where does three meals a day come from?
What does the idea,
and then someone actually put the,
you know,
the by
line,
is it in fact racist?
Like what the fuck?
And then everybody's,
they're saying that three meals a day is racist and then you start tweeting.
It's clickbait.
They fuck.
Yeah.
And this is just this mad rush to get people to read your shit.
Right.
In doing so you've sacrificed all credibility.
Yeah.
And,
and you can be inflammatory about peanuts without being stupid.
I mean,
peanuts are somewhat dangerous.
Uh,
you know,
people's health potentially.
No.
Why don't I read about peanuts has said that it wasn't always the case in that
one of the real concerns about peanut allergies is that keeping kids from
peanuts when they're very young because you're worried about peanut allergies
could in fact be causing peanut allergies.
Yeah.
There was a recently a study that found that by doing a manipulation of gut
bacteria,
they could eliminate peanut allergies in mice.
Really?
Yeah.
So it seems to be some core,
uh,
you know,
functional gut thing that's gone awry to produce peanut allergies in these
individuals.
This doesn't taste that bad.
Which one's that?
The caffeine one.
Yeah,
that's the worst one.
That's the most bitter of all three.
Yeah,
because caffeine is pretty bitter molecule.
Oh,
it is like it has a taste to it.
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
I try decaf verses CAF coffee and you'll,
we'll tell the taste,
the differences,
uh,
bitterness under the caffeine.
Caffeine,
Flint.
Yeah.
There's like a mild or sort of,
what are you thinking about?
Like you ever try that Kopi Luwak that?
No,
I have not tried it to being,
that comes from a civics,
but yeah,
I mean I have a problem paying 70 bucks for a cup of coffee,
first of all.
Uh,
but um,
I have not yet tried the Kopi Luwak.
Yeah.
Bought a bag of it once.
Why bonded?
Um,
uh,
at a place and it was really smooth.
If you haven't heard of it,
what it is,
there's an animal called a civic that is like some type of cat.
Like a weasel.
Yeah.
But I think it's in the cat family and they eat coffee beans and then shit them
out.
And the farmers didn't want to waste these coffee beans so they would literally
pick them out of the Dung of the civic and put it into,
you know,
there'd broast it and it somehow or another stomach acids do something pre
digested.
Yeah.
It makes it like really smooth.
All the enzymes.
But does it affect the caffeine content?
I don't know.
My guess is the roasting is really where that matters the most because you have
to bring the oils out of the beam to the surface and caramelize them or oxidized
and to produce the,
the flavor you're looking for.
So I guess in the long euros,
the more the caffeine goes down and non roasted coffee beans have some sort of
antioxidant effect as well,
right?
Yeah.
The green coffee bean health thing,
the chloro,
what's the word?
Chloro I forget what the compound is.
Yeah.
But there's some antioxidants,
uh,
in,
I mean green,
Brown,
whatever,
coffee.
You have Westerners get more antioxidants from coffee.
I think that all other sources combined,
that's incredible.
You know,
we drink a huge amount of coffee,
but there's a,
there's a lot of benefits.
I mean,
I'm a big fan of the coffee.
Uh,
but it gets demonized,
doesn't it?
It sure does.
I mean,
and there's,
and there's some drawbacks.
Know coffee would not be considered a strict nootropic.
I mean,
my,
my definition for the word nootropic is
improving cognition,
supporting output with no appreciable side effects.
So coffee does not fit.
Doesn't,
doesn't,
it doesn't fit that bar,
but do I use it?
Absolutely.
I mean,
I wake up in the morning,
have too much blood in my caffeine stream,
you and race for the poor over and make one first thing.
Well,
you know,
I'd love it as a ritual.
It's like one of those things,
I just love a warm cup of coffee in the morning.
It's just like,
it feels like this is a nice way to relax your way into the day.
Absolutely.
And the ritual,
a piece of it should not be,
I mean it's,
it's a really big part of it for me.
It gives you a chance to be mindful of when folks come into my office for Qbe,
Geez,
I asked him to abstain from coffee that day or tea or whatever.
And then when they're done I hand them a,
you know,
handcrafted cup of coffee that I've made for that.
Handcrafted is one of my least favorite expression is,
is it really?
Yup.
I'm really getting pissed.
Is it,
is it redundant?
Is that the uh,
it's just one of those things is a handcrafted burger is we won't serve
handcrafted cocktails.
I make,
I make the coffee from my clients when they're,
when they're done their brain map.
The doctor brings you a cup of coffee because it's,
let me give you some good coffee.
My secret stash.
Oh,
what kinds of,
what kind of coffee do you,
I use a mix of small origin,
organic,
you know,
batches I haven't delivered to me from a couple of places in the country.
Yeah.
So there's a place up in Portland,
Oregon that ships me in my little stash,
so,
oh,
that's nice.
Okay,
cool.
Um,
yeah,
I have a,
a bunch of different favorites.
I like the coffees.
Do have a different flavor profile.
Oh yeah,
sure,
sure.
There's some interesting ones out there,
you know.
Um,
I had this guy,
Peter Giuliani Juliano Juliano Juliano,
he's,
um,
a coffee expert.
And,
uh,
he told me that all coffee originates from Ethiopia,
all of it initially,
and that very narrow part of the world it grew in initially.
And that from there they started taking it to all these different parts of the
world where he's like,
Erica or Rebecca Arabic,
how'd he say it?
Or rabbit or Rebecca beans.
They took it to Saudi Arabia and they took it to all these different parts of
South America.
Yeah.
And then they started growing it and all these different places.
But we'd always can think of,
you know,
Columbia's being like,
where did that Dude,
Juan Valdez lives?
I mean,
he's,
he's growing into the awesome coffee.
I actually prefer African coffees to South America.
And typically,
um,
you know,
a little more complexity,
a little darker flavors in them typically.
Well,
he brought me some Ethiopian coffee that tasted like lemons.
Wow.
That's really interesting.
It was like he doesn't drink it with,
with uh,
any cream or anything in it.
So it was just black coffee and it had this like really lemony taste to it.
It's really good.
Interesting,
really good and really unusual.
I was like,
whoa.
And there's a bunch of different weird flavors.
Like Kona is one of my favorites from Hawaii.
Why has some really interesting flavors and you go,
look what this causing this stuff.
It's just altitude,
altitude.
The water boy growing in the soil like Cuban cigars.
Right.
A very distinct flavor,
which we can now legally bring back into the country.
Finally,
I got a hundred bucks worth.
Yeah.
For now.
I mean that,
that's gonna widen them.
Sure.
Yeah.
I'm sure it will officially go now if part of the education group [inaudible]
teaching people shit all the time.
There you go.
Part of an education group.
Thank you.
Having you on this program is educational for the folks that are listening.
So I think I'm a WHO's the Sam?
Not you want him to Cuba.
We should we fuck.
Yeah Dude,
let's do it.
Let's drive one of those old cars you have down there.
They have all these 1950s cars from before the embargo.
Yeah cause they couldn't have me.
We'll get new cars.
Yeah.
For Western cards anyways since then.
But it's sort of like a real knock on consumerism cause they do a great job of
these cars.
These cars are an amazing shaving.
There was this image that I saw recently online of all these people driving
these like 1950s early 1960 cars and they're beautiful.
Really well kept.
I was like,
dad is fascinating.
Like we have this idea that cars,
we have to get a new car every year,
the new cars or we have to have a new model every year.
Whether the new cars have to have a substantial improvement in all areas of
performance and braking and gadgets and all this different jazz.
But they also,
you know,
like a modern car today would not last 50 years on an island.
It's true.
You know too many,
too many complexities to many small electronics.
It just would fall apart.
You know the reason you're,
they have 50 scars and Kubis because you can remain the facture and replace
those parts and keep them running in the way that you would not be able to be
like a Prius or you know,
some modern,
you know,
fuel injected thing,
especially a Prius.
Anything that has batteries.
That's,
that's a huge,
huge issues.
The lithium ion,
the battery cobalt stuff wears out cadmium.
Yeah.
That's one thing that people aren't taking into consideration when they think
about the fact that they're driving.
Some ECO friendly vehicle won't see ECO friendly for right here.
Right.
Not necessarily ecofriendly for it's being pulled out of the ground.
I saw,
I saw an article,
I think it was inflammatory more than real,
but it pointed out that the ownership costs and the impact environmental impact
of a Prius versus at Hummer were equivalent because the Prius has a 100,000 mile
lifespan and has all these really expensive mind battery components to go into
it where a hummer has like a 300,000 mile lifespan and it's just an old
fashioned,
you know,
traditionally engineered car.
Right?
So there's,
there's uh,
uh,
you know,
it's sort of disingenuous though because who the fuck drives a Hummer for
300,000 miles?
Totally.
And,
and you know,
if you dig into the math,
some of it is a little bit bias doesn't seem to work all that well,
but it's not simply that because you drive a car that is electric.
It's not only,
you know,
that's not the only benefit on,
you not buying gas is not the only benefit of having a hybrid.
It would be amazing though to see what would happen if you took every car in Los
Angeles and replaced it with an electric car.
First of all,
there'd be people with dead batteries everywhere.
It'd be assholes that forgot to charge their car blocking the road off,
and because you just,
you don't have the access to charging,
it takes too long leap or late for work.
They don't have that half an hour to get that 50% charge would have fucking
takes,
but the sky would look different.
It might,
I mean the,
the air quality has improved pretty much every year since Reagan and in La,
right in the Reagan was the peak
of the horrible smog.
I have to tell folks that,
you know,
when I go back to visit the northeast where I'm from,
that,
oh yeah,
we don't care.
They make jokes,
but la smog,
it's like,
well,
it's actually not that bad.
There's,
the air quality's pretty darn good.
Especially where I live in west La,
it's where you're getting the wave from the ocean air.
It's,
it's pretty good.
There's the small,
you know,
when I first moved to La in 2005,
I was,
I rode cross country to motorcycle and I was coming down to the San Fernando
Valley and there's this layer of black and orange sludge that I drove down into,
you know,
um,
even that's happening less and less I think.
So I think the,
the sort of southern California,
you know,
Smaug trope is really overblown these days.
Well the smog laws that they put in place and the small screens that you have to
put your car through there,
pretty substantial and they're doing,
they're doing a good job as far as that.
And it makes it very difficult for you to take cars post 1975 pre 1975 they're
exempt.
But Post 1975 cars,
like this is a lot of them that have a huge issue getting smogged.
Getting spawn cleared.
Yeah.
I have a,
I have a one that's postdoc,
but it's a diesel,
so it's exempt.
Oh,
stinky.
That runs on vegetable ale.
Oh,
you one of those guys.
I've,
I've a couple of vehicles.
One's a Veggie oil,
a diesel and ones that motorcycle.
Yeah.
I have a of a traditional gas car too.
But now when you say runs on vegetable oil,
where do you get your vegetables?
Um,
I haven't been driving it too much,
so nowhere recently.
But I have a friend from Inglewood who had a small company.
He delivers it and he would deliver a gallons of,
you know,
sort of reclaimed waste vegetable oil.
He was clean.
Yeah,
they kick it.
I had a buddy of mine have converted,
he bought an old Mercedes whole diesel.
Those are the best ones to convert.
And you converted it to kitchen oil and he would get it from restaurants by
their kitchen.
Oh,
exactly.
Now these days,
I mean 20 years ago you could do that.
These days there's entire companies that have relationships with the Japanese
Chinese restaurants to do this and to resell it as a commercial company.
But what kind of gas mileage to get with one of those cars?
I mean,
um,
I was getting more than 30 miles a gallon with diesel still as an immediate
early eighties car.
And I think I lose one mile per gallon and Veggie oil.
So instead of like 30 you'd get like 29 roles again,
31 to 30 or something.
And is it a large vehicle?
You're talking about 300 CD Mercedes,
you know like 3,500 pound vehicle,
big heavy two door Mercedes,
but still a big one.
It's not very heavy.
3,500 isn't that really heavy compared to a modern car?
Sure.
Really?
Yeah.
What do you think a modern car weighs?
Uh,
18 to 2,500 I mean,
I guess that's crazy.
No,
that you,
that's like a really,
really light sports car.
Like A,
like a 1970 Porsche with everything stripped out with no radio,
no heat.
If you're lucky,
you know,
if that's true,
cause I had a 200 pounds,
I had a early eighties Oldsmobile Delta 88 they hold land yacht and nothing was
only 4,200 pounds.
That doesn't make sense either.
Are you sure?
Yeah,
because I have a nine 11 Porsche nine 11 gt three Rs,
which is the lightest model they make.
It's 3000 pounds and it's very light.
It's extremely
light.
I mean,
they,
it has carbon fibers,
seats,
they strip out all the sound deadening and it's like you should make it as light
as possible.
No,
I'm 100% positive.
All right.
I'm,
I'm actually pretty deep in this world of lightening cars.
Like they drill into foot pedals to make the car lighter,
lighter.
They drill into the handle the door,
like to take a tea.
You've ever seen a 1972,
nine 11.
Yeah.
It's a tiny car.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
not smaller than a nine 11 of today.
If you're lucky,
you get one of those down to 2,200 pounds.
If you're really a fucking psycho,
you can get it down to like maybe 1800 but you have to use carbon fiber fenders,
fiberglass fenders,
things along those lines.
You,
you really compromise a lot of,
uh,
no comfort at all?
No.
The dashboards,
my Mercedes,
I'm not sure in what ways,
but it's a heavy car.
It's not,
it's not a light low key tiny car.
It can be 3,500 pounds,
but I mean like a BMW m three for instance.
Which is a sporty car.
I have,
I have a mini Cooper,
a modern one that's,
you know,
that's a small lightweight,
that's very level.
Yeah.
But an m three,
which is not a big car is 3,900 pounds.
Wow.
I'm surprised.
Yeah.
Most people are.
The most people think their cars are lighter than they really are.
Like A,
for instance,
like a dodge challenger.
She loves new dodge challengers.
You're looking at about 4,500 pounds.
Yeah.
It doesn't look like it would be,
no,
not at all.
Not at all.
You're dealing with V eight engines,
metal frames.
Interesting.
All that jazz.
Yeah.
People would be surprised at how heavy your shit is.
Like I have a Lexus x Suv,
you know those big,
that's like 6,000 pounds at fuck.
Oh my God,
he fat pig.
So maybe they're getting heavier.
Getting to that as,
as uh,
you know,
we built more things onto these vehicles with it,
trying to make a lot more cars out of aluminum.
Now.
Like Ford has done that.
They released a new truck with a aluminum frame,
right?
Yes.
They'd done that with their F-150 and they reduced it by more than 700 pounds.
I was a steel before,
I assume.
Yeah,
frame.
But it's amazing because the new aluminum that they're using are just as strong,
if not stronger in some ways than steel,
you know,
and they're substantially lighter.
It was really incredible benefits far as like gas mileage and all those things.
Yeah.
The,
the way they construct him is a little bit different,
but so far,
no,
a detriment.
The New Range Rover is doing the same thing.
The new range rover is cuts somewhere between six and 700 pounds from their cars
as well.
Okay.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Well,
you know,
regardless of the,
it doesn't matter of the weight of the NBC,
it's a,
you know,
I'm still getting 30 miles to the gallon.
Diesel diesel is way more efficient,
right?
Yeah.
Well it's,
it's,
it's compression.
The compression it does,
it doesn't explode the fuel.
It burns,
it releases the gases.
So it's not a,
it's an explosive decompression.
So it's much more efficient.
Neil young has like a ranch in northern California where he grows his own
plants.
Can make these Tim into bio diesel and powers his own vehicles for his own
diesel creation.
Closed loop and then Amaziah.
I love it.
He's a pretty amazing guy.
He's the best,
he's a fascinating dude.
He had some weird project he was doing though that everybody was like,
all right,
good luck with that.
He was trying to make some super expensive MP,
three player that recreated the sound of,
of a vinyl or as close to it as possible.
And he had a go fund me or a Kickstarter or some shit like that.
And people are like,
what?
First of all,
no one's given Neil young money.
It's not happening,
dude.
Your richest fuck thousand Acre ranch in northern California.
You're making your own diesel.
All right.
Go spend your money.
Right,
right,
right.
So like that was problematic,
but it was also like the,
the shape of this thing.
It was like a,
you know,
those below Roni,
whatever those chocolate bars,
that's what it looked like,
like a pyramid shape,
but long,
you know,
and uh,
he pull it,
pull it up.
Jamie.
This is a fucking disaster.
I mean it never went anywhere and then we gave a shit about it.
But the idea behind it was to create a richer sound that sort of emulates the
actual recording.
Your original recording of the,
of the MP three so then it reproduces it without the lossy sorta compression.
Yeah.
So to take this compressed sound and converted into something that has like more
depth,
more richness to Sony has a new thing that they just announced.
Two here.
Here it is the Pono highest resolution.
See how it looks like a chocolate bar that will oh yeah.
Weird fucking shape thing.
Does anybody buying those things Jamie?
No.
That he's buying a fucking thing.
Neil Young.
How dare you?
How dare you waste your time.
You Genius Looks Kinda like a Nintendo a yeah,
something game controllers.
Yeah,
it's,
it's very odd looking device and it kinda got trumped recently because Sony just
released some new version of a Walkman.
It's much thicker.
It's heavy.
It looks like a cell phone.
It looks almost like an iPhone,
but it's only for mp3s and there's Sony version is just much,
much.
It's a much more powerful as far as its ability to much more powerful than,
than your phone rather.
I don't know if it's more powerful than Neil Young's creation.
Can we get away from things here?
Um,
mindfulness,
mindfulness.
What do,
what do you mean by mindfulness?
When you say mindfulness,
that's one of those terms that like people go,
oh,
I'm not religious,
but I'm spiritual.
You know,
practicing mindfulness.
It's,
I love it as a,
as a,
as a thought,
but I don't like all the baggage that's attached.
And I think that most people who aren't doing it and don't know what it is,
and I say,
you know,
developing meditation practices would be good for you.
And I get the response,
oh,
I can never shut my mind.
Well that isn't the point of meditating.
It's like,
you know,
the point of going into the gym is not to be strong.
The play is to lift weights like this.
There's an exercise.
Meditation is a practice you do,
and you might get to a quieter mind,
but the practice is not quieting your mind.
Right.
So to answer your question,
mindfulness is paying attention to the present moment in a specific way on
purpose.
Now that sounds simple.
It is,
but it's not really simple
in practice is it?
For most folks it is.
It actually is.
Well,
this doesn't may even types of meditation,
right?
That the classic meditations of a Pasta,
Samatha metal,
these are all fairly similar in that you pick something,
some anchor to hold your attention on and then simply you notice when you've
drifted,
since you have a mind,
it will drift.
It'll get,
you know,
fantasize,
dream,
remember,
wish,
plan,
and we noticed you're not holding that attention.
Focus,
that anchor,
you release whatever ever it is you've gotten distracted by and bring your
attention back to the anchor.
And that's the rep of meditation.
That's it.
Oh,
I'm,
I'm supposed to be thinking about this sound or my watching my breath or he
listened to one,
you know,
note or something in a,
in a music play.
Oh,
I've gotten distracted.
let it go.
Not now.
Back to the focus again and again and again and again.
And that's the entirety of most classic meditation is noticing when you've
gotten distracted,
you've left your anchor of your attention,
put down the distraction,
go back to the anchor.
So it's not a loss.
When you get distracted.
Not only is it not a loss if you want getting distracted,
you probably aren't alive.
You know,
if you have a mind,
it will get distracted.
That's what they do.
You know,
your mind pays attention to your pain,
your distractions,
your wishes,
your fantasies,
your memories.
I mean,
it's doing all of these things.
If you,
if you're able to sit down and shut your mind off,
you probably don't have one.
So when people talk about the difficulty that they have in meditation,
you think they'd probably get to that step and they go,
God can't do it.
And they,
yeah,
and they're,
and they're basically saying,
I'm not any good at it.
Instead of saying,
well,
being good at it or not is not the point.
The point is doing it.
You know,
if you went to the gym and pumped iron and a bunch of bench presses,
were you good at it?
Well,
maybe,
maybe like a PR,
a personal record or something,
but going versus not going is what matters.
Not critiquing necessarily every little bit of what you do.
Some people are terrified though,
of silence.
Terrified of silence and just being sitting alone doing nothing.
It's like no,
they would rather climb a fucking mountain in their underwear.
Then just sit alone in a room by themselves.
Okay,
I'm going to leave you here for three hours.
You can't talk.
I just want you to breathe in three hours in a scary too.
Right?
And can you tell people,
here's how you should meditate.
And you know,
they go to a meditation class,
like a Buddhist center and they have to sit there for an hour and a half.
That's a big ask initially.
So I often tell folks 20 minutes,
you know,
even that can be a big ask for some folks.
So I say,
you know,
take your first five minutes and do a concentration practice.
Took a very narrow focus.
Like watch the sensation of air crossing her upper lip.
Just pay attention to that tickle.
That's it.
Very narrow,
tight spacial focus.
And do that for five minutes.
By the end of that time,
your mind's probably a little more stable.
And then do what I call an awareness or insight practice.
Watch more rhythmic things like your breath rise and fall or the sound of
traffic going by the road or something.
And we see your mind is more stable.
Like how so?
Well you have less random things popping up in your mind after doing some
concentration practice.
There's less.
It feels less busy,
less of the monkey mind chatter.
It's still there,
but it's a little less insistent when you've done some concentration practice.
I mean concentrating on anything sort of re uh,
directs your attention,
resources and what you're thinking about.
And if what you're really thinking about is simply attending,
focusing for its own sake,
then you build those resources and build more strength and resources in
focusing.
And so then later on when you're walking around the world,
you have a more spacious mind.
You have some space between your thoughts,
your less automatically reactive.
You're going to cut somebody off in traffic and you know,
pick them the bird.
Um,
these are all things that happened as a consequence of developing more
resources.
So what you do on the cushion or wherever you happen to meditate translates to
less reactivity,
more sustained focus,
better attention,
better sleep,
less anxiety,
less anger,
but you weren't practicing all those things.
Those things come from having more stable attention,
more stable executive function.
I sort of feel like a lot of people operate on momentum and that they kind of,
that momentum oftentimes is like nipping at their heels and they can never rest.
It's like the momentum of all their past actions and thoughts and the things
they have to deal with in their life,
their bills,
their responsibilities,
all that stuff is sort of pushing you.
Sure.
And when they go to bed,
they're like,
their head is still spinning.
I can't stop thinking.
I got to keep my mouth shut your mind off.
And all this background noise starts to rise to the surface.
Sure.
Yeah.
Uh,
meditation is something that can quiet that.
Absolutely.
It will help you choose how you react.
I mean,
I did the,
the phrase I use is intention versus momentum.
You learn to choose and to act versus react and to be,
you know,
act from a place of choice and control instead of always,
reeling based on your environment.
Do you use sensory deprivation tanks?
I have a,
I have not.
It might be fun to do,
you know,
considering I have a sort of static Shamana you have,
you have,
I have not.
I'm not you slip tanks.
No,
I've never,
I've never had a float tank.
That's crazy.
And I know,
right.
I've never,
uh,
never ended up in one a really.
I've been interested in it,
but never quite happen.
So how does it kind of like,
you not get into that,
that seems really bizarre to try everything.
I mean,
there's all kinds of things that I've gotten into.
Yeah.
But that's the mother fucker.
I can't believe you haven't tried that.
I've had,
I've had one of my basement for the past 15 years.
[inaudible] 13.
And is it a body temperature,
Epsom salts kind of thing?
Yeah.
Well,
um,
our started doing it in the early two thousands.
I,
um,
I went to a place and tried it out for the first time and I was hooked.
I read about it,
seen the altered states movie,
got excited about it,
read John Lilly's book the deep self.
And um,
if you've never done it,
it's,
it's meditation times a hundred.
Sure.
Because you don't feel your body,
you look literally detached from the bottom,
right.
Once you become relaxed enough to
do the same meditation practices concentrate,
I um,
uh,
I concentrate on my breath.
That's what I do in with the good out with the bad.
And I do it over a long period of time.
Like I,
I like to do a one minute breath.
I like to do one minute in and one minute and out because it's very difficult
and requires a lot of discipline.
It requires a lot of discipline.
Not to just exhale all your air show right away,
but in doing so it,
that's like the base,
that's what,
that's how I build up my,
and then anything after that is easy.
And,
um,
the focus on the breath,
it takes away from freaking out about the fact that are floating around this
tank and you don't feel your body and the absence of sensory perception and you
don't really not getting anything in there.
You're getting a little bit of movement.
Sometimes your body will develop like itches like,
God,
I got to Itch my face.
Yeah.
And it's really don't,
it's not eating like you didn't get bit by a fucking mosquito.
You're just freaking out.
It's like random sensory.
Yeah.
Your brain's freaking out because it's not getting any input.
So it starts creating norms.
There's,
there's lots of yeah.
Ways you can sort of trick the brain into producing input like that even without
climbing into a float tank.
Uh,
the simplest hack for that is probably,
um,
someone called Ganzfeld classes,
take a ping pong cut in half,
trim the edges,
they aren't sharp and essentially make a pair of goggles where you're covering
each tie with the ping pong,
half ping pong ball and then sit and look through the,
the white balls,
um,
at a,
at a white wall that you're protecting light onto.
So there's some indirect light and keep your eyes open to stare at the inside to
these curved spaces.
You can't resolve distance who can't resolve a flat surface and after a few
minutes you start hallucinating interest.
The same thing you experience.
I'm sharing.
You have some,
some hallucinations when your visions,
when you're deep in your,
in your float tank too,
right?
Yeah.
You certainly do the same exact thing.
It's triggered within moments sometimes for some people a few minutes anyways
with Ganzfeld cause the eyes being open and trying to look,
but not seeing any surface.
It's a very similar phenomenon I about to your float tank.
Yeah,
I bet it is.
The difference being that in the float tank,
one of the benefits of it is the fact that either
the absence of sensory dep or sensory input,
it seems like your brain has way more resources.
So it seems like problems seemed to be easier to fix.
Yup.
They've seemed to,
solutions seem to be more apparent.
You just have a better understanding of things.
Yeah.
You know,
I think why haven't gotten into float tanks because I have other,
you know,
ecstatic,
meaning taking you out of ordinary reality.
I have other techniques that work really well for me.
And then I,
I tend to use,
you know,
like,
like rhythmic movement until your mind shifts.
Um,
and then for technology assisted stuff,
I mean,
I,
I run a neurofeedback center.
I can put you in a state in half an hour,
you know,
with wires on your head.
And so if I want to dial in a specific state,
I will dial in a specific state for myself.
This is a massive benefit to the tank.
I would really love you to experience it and then hear what your,
your thoughts on it are.
Because it's,
I'll send you down to the lab in Venice.
You're in the west side?
Yeah,
I live in Culver city.
Yeah.
The float lab is the spot.
This,
I mean,
this guy crashed who's created these tanks.
It's got the most advanced tanks.
Have a friend of a friend.
Actually,
I,
uh,
I've heard of him.
So yeah,
he's a master when it comes to that.
He's really when,
when the entire float world was building these flimsy plastic sort of shitty
things are those things.
Yeah.
He came up with this giant steel walled structure.
It looks like a meat locker.
Okay.
His,
they're far more insulated.
They retain heat better.
The linings are far thicker.
He uses the same lines that they use it.
They make Koi ponds.
Everything he built to the 10th degree.
Yeah.
I'm just in checking it out.
Uh,
might be some way we could do under,
your head's not immerse does it?
No boats under half water.
Your bodies floating.
Right.
So if you're lying on your back,
I would love to get your water,
but you can't do EEG underwater.
So we're wet electrics.
So what couldn't you develop some uh,
electric?
Where are you attaching the electrode?
Scalp,
scalp.
All over the scalp.
Yeah.
Differently.
He could you pro,
it's a grid to the frontal area.
It wouldn't give you the w wouldn't be the thing with EEG is to compare your
results to any existing literature.
You have to record the same spot at the same distribution of spots.
But there'd be a way to do it inside some sort of a divers camp.
There might be.
Yeah,
exactly.
There are a few,
there are a few ways that this might be accomplished because I've seen EEG done
on actual divers like unschooled divers.
So there probably are ways of like electrodes that can get where that you can
serve seal against the scalp with Colloidal,
you know,
gels and um,
but I would love to see what happens to brands under that altered state.
Yeah,
I would love to see you try it.
I'd love to see you do some tests on it.
Crashes also developing some sort of a weird video component to his tanks where
he has a engineered these screens to have the lowest amount of light emission
that you can possibly have while still seeing the image so that these images,
cause you're in complete silence,
complete darkness.
I mean you,
you don't,
there's no light in there at all.
So having this incredibly minimal amount of light on these screens,
you can see the images,
but you don't see the television.
I don't see that the screen itself and he believes in,
in the absence of sensory input,
we'll your,
your brain having more resources,
you can take an information better so you can learn quicker.
I mean,
I think it's probably very likely.
Yeah.
Less distraction.
And also you can do things if you did things from first person perspective,
if you had videos of people learning things from first person perspective,
it could sync up in your mind,
you know,
interesting.
It must happen to mirror neurons in some way.
Well,
it's just theoretical at this point.
I don't think he's actually achieved it.
I mean he's,
he's,
I know he's got the tank set up right now with this,
uh,
this video,
maybe you could tell,
it sounds like we need to do is as out of bio feedback and put it to it where
what you're seeing is contingent on your brain moving and specific directions.
Mm.
Yeah.
And then you could actually could,
I mean,
if the float tanks putting you into this receptive state and deep
state quickly,
and it sounds like it is with biofeedback,
you could probably,
you know,
like incredibly powerfully just move people across state shifts.
Let's see.
Only atmosphere that I know of,
the only environment where your body is literally untethered from your mind.
You don't feel anything you feels like you're flying,
like just floating through the unit and there's a weird Lucian of motion that
you get when you're in that thing.
When you,
you floating for a while,
you feel like you're flying,
like you feel like you're flying forward.
Interesting.
Like you're moving,
there's a feeling of movement.
Can you feel gravity now?
Okay.
You're totally floating because of the fact that there's a thousand pounds of
salt and this water and the water being 93.5 degrees,
right flow or 94 some people you're floating in a very buoyant,
not feeling anything.
Yeah.
The water becomes your air,
the air becomes your skin.
It's all one thing and you're just no more input and he does.
Cool.
Yeah.
Total darkness.
It sounds like.
I'd love to hear more about how you haven't fucked with that yet.
It seems like something right up your alley.
It does.
Actually.
I,
it's probably just a function of I am a one guy,
you know,
it's too many things.
I mean,
I've,
I lived about a lot of different lives,
different careers.
It sounds like crazy.
Shumon wacky text.
Right man.
I mean,
I started Grad school at age 35 digit really?
You know,
uh,
it had other careers before that.
Like what are the careers?
Oh,
let's see.
Um,
I worked in patient psychiatric crisis for many years.
Uh,
that must have been fun.
Yeah,
that was kind of crazy.
I'm the most violent hospital in the state of Massachusetts.
Oh,
we're doing five,
10,
15 restraints,
a shift.
When I first got there.
Wow.
And after a year I took over training people how to do restraints and that's why
he started lifting weights.
No,
I was,
I was actually really into I Quito back then.
And uh,
that's about safe management of safe energy or not getting hurt when people are
throwing punches basically.
And,
uh,
I took over training the restraint team and after another year we were down to
like one a month because it was,
some of it was the expectations we're setting on the patients in the hospital.
You know,
the conflict was,
was there,
right.
Like oftentimes people discuss that when they talk about police violence that
the much of the violence that they get involved and to be mitigated if they had
a better way of communicating.
Sure.
Absolutely.
Um,
so I did that.
I,
my first jobs were working on farms and a little farming town in the northeast.
Picked Berries.
Hmm.
Uh,
I was a baker and caterer for a few years.
I worked in residential homes with retarded and multiply disabled adults.
Um,
worked in high tech for several years,
worked in the middleware where database company for a few years I worked for
neurofeedback guy,
I worked for an MRI imaging center doing a prediction of depression,
relapse based on brain changes with withdrew their meds.
Um,
you know,
so really a pretty broad,
high tech human services.
And then now I'm sort of combining the two.
Uh,
how much work do you do with people that have encountered traumatic brain
injuries?
More than I thought I would be.
Um,
you know,
neurofeedback is largely tuning circuits that exist.
Um,
and Tbi is traumatic head injuries.
Brain injuries are often different.
Architecture of the brain has been physically traumatized.
Um,
some Tbi people,
I can make really quick changes.
I have one client right now,
she came to see me.
She was having some tremors,
an opposite side from the head injury.
She was having a lot of impulsivity,
which is a pretty standard thing when you're,
you know,
head injured either.
The impulsivity is a weird,
wasn't it?
Yeah,
it's pretty dramatic.
Um,
often for head injuries and,
uh,
you know,
she's now finishing her 30 sessions.
She's gone off all of her meds.
She knows her on any anticonvulsant.
She's not on any,
any anti,
uh,
impulsivity meds in those four sleep meds.
So her brain change very,
very quickly,
uh,
and,
and sort of in the direction I was hoping it would.
And it,
it sort of just did what I asked it to.
Um,
I had a client last year who came to see me.
I just couldn't get his brain moving.
There was just too much going on.
Um,
so I so do you mean by and couldn't get his brain?
I couldn't get his frequencies to train up or down enough.
I couldn't get his symptoms to shift.
He was,
you know,
get worn out at,
new and every day and he was really impulsive and all the standard Tbi stuff.
Um,
so I think I've worked in the past decade with about seven or eight Tbi people
and you know,
three of them were dramatic responders and a couple were tough,
you know,
tough movers.
Cause so this guy that you couldn't yeah,
him to move.
What did you want to,
um,
you know,
he ended up going overseas to teach English.
He sort of,
he had an end to the time that I had him because he was going to the next job,
which was overseas.
So I only had him for like six or eight weeks or something.
So had I had him,
I would've said,
look,
me,
stop billing you,
which is what I do when I don't make results.
It doesn't happen very often,
but I suddenly stopped billing you and then just keep training and keep trying
different things until I find something that works for your specific brain.
And so it takes some of the pressure off them but not making them financial.
Yeah,
exactly.
So I signed people up for like a 30 session package,
which costs some money,
you know,
cost about one of our four k and um,
90% or more of people that brains do exactly what I ask and they're,
they're really happy with the results.
Does insurance cover that?
Sometimes?
Um,
depends,
you know,
uh,
um,
alternatives,
which is where I do neurofeedback is not a provider for any insurance.
So if you've got a PPO or something,
we can often submit against it for partial reimbursements are things,
um,
the addiction side of alternatives.
We actually are getting pretty good coverage these days.
I'm doctor Jaffe and Kern just got the center certified as an outpatient partial
hospitalization day program.
That's the non 12 step.
Uh,
in treatment program we have there,
it says gentlemen that you weren't getting results with.
What was his issue?
He had some sort of a concussion.
Massive,
yeah.
A car accident.
Yeah.
And He,
and he went coma for many weeks,
lost a big chunk of his brain in the front.
And so we had massive impulsivity cause the frontal lobe again is your
inhibitor.
It's so like as far as drinking sexual things all speeding,
it was sort of like acquired ADHD.
He sort of acquired it in his mid forties because of this head injury.
We had no self control.
Said what every,
you know,
inappropriate.
Um,
you know,
and then he would get worn out by one o'clock every day,
noon,
one o'clock.
You just,
this is done,
which is really common in Tbi just to not having any mental stamina.
And so for him it was let's get your sleep better because he wasn't sleeping
well,
let's make your daytime energy better and let's get you less impulsive with a
goals.
And those things all moved.
But they moved,
you know,
a fraction.
What I really wanted them to move.
And most people,
the reason why it was so frustrating because for most people,
neurofeedback is sort of a,
you know,
it's my silver bullet.
I can do lots of things with it.
I expect that nine or more than 910 people will just,
you know,
their brains will do what I ask,
even if they're dramatically impaired,
you know,
profoundly,
uh,
you know,
self stemming autistics people with major PTSD or major alcoholism or a lot of
really common presentation these days is,
um,
people that have been on sleeping meds for decades and they aren't working and
they can't sleep at,
but they're still on massive amounts of sleeping,
sleeping,
Tambien type things,
all kinds of things.
What are you thoughts on those?
Um,
the short answer is there's no such thing as a sleeping mat.
None of these sleep drugs make you sleep.
They all are hypnotics.
They,
they put you in a trance like state.
They sedate you into a hypnosis or hypnotic state.
And then if you're tired and the normal sleep reflexes there,
it takes over and you fall asleep.
But it didn't put you in a sleep state.
It puts you in a hypnotic state,
which is very different than a sleep state.
I have some friends that have real problems with those things and they have to
take them all the time.
Or they do take them all the time.
They think they have to take and they don't work after taking them for a while.
So people come to see me and say,
I've been taking sleep nug drugs for,
you know,
10 20 years and I haven't slept well in 10 years.
And so I start training up.
There are frequencies that caused deeper sleep at night.
More relaxation,
you know,
this is about sleep architecture is maintained by specific frequencies in the
brain.
Sleep spindles until I'll train those up,
make them stronger so they able to fall asleep more easily,
stay asleep more easily,
wake up more refreshed.
So I have a friend and he takes two a day.
It takes two of those fucking ambien things at night.
He scares the shit out of me.
Everyone's always worried he's not going to wake up one day.
Yeah.
Um,
what would you do to that guy?
I would say,
you know,
how comfortable are you,
reducing your ambien?
And usually the answer is,
I can't.
So,
okay,
let's move.
Okay,
let's forget him.
He's a junkie.
Let's,
uh,
let's go.
I mean,
Ambia Junkie,
it's probably a junkie for some other shit too.
Let's,
uh,
let's go with someone who just has a problem sleeping,
doesn't take anything.
It takes a little Tylenol pm or so.
I would just start training that.
I'm doing a brain map and Brighton assessment,
figure out which patterns are driving their sleep issues.
And usually it's some of the patterns evolving,
too much Beta activity toward the middle and back of the head.
Sometimes it's the same patterns that are producing some anxiety formations.
And so I'll find these patterns and then I'll just start training,
you know,
decreasing amounts of Beta,
increased amounts of Alpha or theta,
bringing those slower brainwaves up,
um,
maybe train up the sleep spindles,
which is what keeps you deeply asleep once you fall asleep.
It prevents you from kind of being woken by all the outside stimuli.
And what would you train this with,
with biofeedback in a measure?
Because you're making all brainwaves all the time.
This something people often don't know.
Right now,
Joe,
you're making Delta Theta,
Alpha,
Beta,
gamma,
and other brainwaves.
We haven't named.
You're making all of them all the time are the ones we have a named who we
haven't identified them either identified that we haven't really named them,
you know,
the,
uh,
in,
in order of,
uh,
um,
of discovery.
Alpha was the first one.
Alpha is the first Greek letter,
but Alphas,
how about 10 hertz,
10 cycles per second,
and there's at least two or three waves slower than alpha that we discovered
later.
So in order going from slow to fast,
it's Delta Theta,
Alpha,
Beta,
gamma,
and gamma traditionally stops at 40 hertz,
40 cycles per second.
But brainwaves go up to about two or even 300 cycles per second.
Wow.
But we haven't actually given those functional,
you know,
bands,
different names beyond gamma.
So is it bio,
is there any biodiversity?
Does everybody have the same sort of frequencies?
Everyone has the same functional frequencies,
but you know,
you might have more alpha than I do,
you know,
as a,
as a baseline.
And so when I'm doing the brain maps,
this is a really good question.
When doing the brain maps,
I'll take baselines.
Let's have you sit with your eyes closed for five minutes and record your eyes
closed,
you know,
resting state and the little court eyes open,
resting state,
the brains very different eyes open and eyes closed.
I'm in very,
very different typically.
And so I'll take that baseline data and compare it to a normative database with
thousands of brains in it and get heat maps.
Picture maps out of that,
that tell me how different you are than the population.
Statistically.
How much of that varies based on intention based on not much at all.
A Q EEG or brain map is stable year after year,
after year after year,
barring maturation medication or head injury.
What about sleep?
Um,
if somebody is really sleep deprived,
there are some differences in the Qeg but if they're a little bit,
a little bit of vagaries and sleep here and there don't actually affect the,
um,
the sleep is much more important.
Like caffeine status and psychostimulant status.
Those things are much bigger deal.
When I'm doing brain recordings then how rested you,
I mean,
folks come in having not slept.
It's not a very valid reading or having been,
you know,
drunk the night before.
It's not a valid reading.
But if someone's just like,
oh I got seven hours,
not nine hours,
not no problem,
you know,
and then statistically we say,
okay,
you know,
let's say your brain has x amount of Alpha with your eyes open.
If it's too much,
that means your spacey,
too much data.
It means you're impulsive.
Too Much Beta in the back might mean you're anxious,
you know,
different asymmetries in the front,
maybe depressed.
And so I'll see five to 10 of these big patterns.
I draw some arbitrary line in the sand,
you know,
more than one and a half standard deviations I consider clinically relevant are
problematic.
Maybe.
And then we sit and talk about all these patterns that rise to that,
you know,
outlier level and try to figure out,
well,
you know,
this one can mean this.
Is that true for you?
Oh it is?
Okay,
great.
Let's believe that one.
This one can mean this.
This one can be in this,
this,
oh,
this one isn't true.
Okay,
let's a normal variant for you.
Let's move on.
So these are not diagnostic tests.
They're more sort of prognostic,
where I'm guessing about what might be true.
But the pattern,
the brain mapping patterns don't fit into nice diagnostic boundaries.
So,
you know,
I might see like a really dramatic ADHD pattern and the person reports somewhat
mild attention problems.
But you know,
if there's a dramatic outlier,
three,
four standard deviations out of range,
chances are very good.
That thing is causing you some trouble in some way.
I would like to do this,
but I'm worried that I might find that I'm way more fucked up than I think I am.
Well,
everyone's a little bit fucked up,
you know?
I mean,
all brains are different.
What about the Dalai Lama?
He's pretty fucked up too.
He has got that stupid robot didn't heal.
Do you have a major health crisis recently?
I don't know.
I think he did.
Yeah.
I just say that I have a friend who had some experience with them,
so he's kind of full of shit.
Yeah.
I have a friend who grew up with them actually,
and they grew up together in a,
in a monastery and uh,
that's hilarious.
He doesn't say much about him,
but,
but you know,
he's,
he's also Tibetan guy,
so he's pretty chill.
So it's a weird way to live your life,
uh,
as the reincarnation of a Godhead,
a spiritual leader.
Yeah,
I would say so.
I think Steven Seagal was one of those two,
according to him,
didn't he gained some sort of reincarnation status?
Did he as an Aikido master?
I'm sure initially was trained by the guy that was his first teacher.
And,
um,
that teacher,
I do not like teach us through pain and intimidation.
Um,
I,
I'm not terribly impressed with as a kito how dare you.
I know it's,
it makes it,
he's gonna come kick my ass now.
But um,
you know,
I'm a Nike I a person and that I haven't done it in a few years,
but uh,
I'm not that impressed with [inaudible] lineage or his onscreen.
Hito wow.
How rude.
I know,
I know.
I'm such a jerk.
Can't even believe you're saying this.
Well,
I don't understand the Kido that much,
so I'm sure you would know more than me.
To me it looks cool flipping people around.
Sure.
Yeah.
It looks like you have to cooperate.
It doesn't look very job.
It would work.
I think if you shot a double on him and got a good grip on your hands,
he's,
he's going for a ride.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
you know,
most of a Keto is learning to recognize force coming at you and not being in the
way of it.
Right.
He's just,
just creep up on them slow and punched him in the face as long as you're not
like running at him like with your hand over your head like,
right.
Exactly.
Although you know you couldn't,
you know,
the angle of the hips in the eyes and you can sort of,
there's a lot of,
the key to like a lot of martial arts is very heavy in the foot work.
So you need to stepped to one side and pivot around and by the time they've
swung their fists there overbalanced now and you can just got to,
you know,
knock them over.
Yeah.
But you take an Ncaa d one wrestler,
good luck.
Put One of those guys against,
you know,
oh Sensei or some of the people,
the pinnacle of the Kido and I'd love to see that against me.
Kicked my ass against the best guy.
You bring your best guy.
I don't get there.
They're actually a,
we're in the 70s several videotaped multi,
a multi martial art competitions expositions between Oh sensai the founder and
several other principals of other martial arts.
Can you wash it online?
You can,
yeah,
yeah.
It was like to watch that.
So how do you say this guy's name?
Oh,
we say,
oh,
sensei.
Oh.
And in sound seems to be Sensei.
He has as a name that I remember,
but,
uh,
he was,
he's noticed,
oh,
Sensei and Akita.
What do you recommend?
A look what videos are one specific problem.
And I could look at it as an exposition video,
like the 70s that's sort of the big one that that shows him,
you know,
knocking people love without touching them and things,
it's a little crazy.
A little,
yeah.
But like,
like not,
not his friends,
like,
you know,
the karate master from Japan getting knocked over and things without him
touching them.
Just a few of that worked.
Um,
and knowing what you know about the mind,
probably because he,
you know,
gave us subtle cue that made them prepare to move in one way and then switched
it.
And you know,
they've essentially using their mind against them,
over balancing them.
You know,
you believe that?
Yeah.
Really.
You think that a guy can knock a guy over with his mind just by giving them
subtle cues,
like shifting your weight to the person attacking,
you've shifted their weight and then move and then moving out of the way it's
the person falls over.
That doesn't work.
That is only going to work on someone that doesn't know how to fight 100% well.
You should look at some of these videos.
There were a lot of them right now with you.
Okay.
Because,
let's see if you could pull that up.
I have a vast extensive experience in watching bullshit,
especially martial arts bullshit and a lot of it comes from these traditional
martial artists that claim to be able to anticipate and use people's,
well.
There's very good claims being made by sentence say in fact,
and he doesn't claim that he has some ancient lineage that came down from the
mountain.
He created it from Tai-chi and Morrison Sword Forms and everything else.
It's a modern art,
not an ancient art.
Well,
there's some,
there's some martial arts that are very,
the ancient martial arts that are very effective and actual hand to hand
competition.
Like judo for instance,
is very effective.
Jujitsu,
of course,
a derivative of an Akita.
It's really a hard martial art.
Like,
like a judo.
I mean like you know is a judicious judo,
Jujitsu.
It's in that category,
but it's softer than judo or cream food.
Redistribution of energy.
Martial art.
Take someone's energy,
use it against them.
The issue is,
is this the gentleman?
So sensei?
Yeah.
So this is someone coming at them.
Okay,
this is terrible.
Show me something good because this guy doesn't know what the fuck he's doing.
All kinds of running into him.
So this is the thing with all these,
these goddamn demonstrations.
Is that guys willingly corroborating well,
yeah.
I mean look at that.
He's practicing the technique and the technique.
You either cooperate or your arm breaks.
Well,
this isn't even cooperating.
This guy's throwing himself on the ground.
So silly.
This guy's a running towards him and letting this guy clothes line.
I'm come on.
That doesn't ever happen.
The guys just standing there.
This would never work against a trained fighter.
Never.
Not in a million years.
You get an Ncaa Division one wrestler,
he's going to shoot on this guy and this guy is going to be on his head in
seconds.
It just doesn't work.
This is,
I mean this is what I'm looking at.
I'm looking at the time.
Well you're,
you're looking at people practicing techniques,
not a multi see the multi,
what should he look for?
A exposition,
I think.
And I think it was in Japan.
Maybe an exhibition or exposition.
Uh,
exhibition.
Exhibition.
Not Exposition.
Yeah.
Exhibition telling me one of those looks a,
and then I think he'd,
he'd put either judo or karate and you'll also find it,
cause it was a multi martial art meeting in the 70s there's a lot of fuckery
when it comes to martial arts and a lot of people that get trapped into all this
fuckery.
And I've met a lot of people that are very intelligent people that swear at
their Sensei is the guy that has the answers to all this jazz.
And I just have,
I've seen too much.
I know how much of it is based on predisposed,
predetermined ideas that you have about this person's abilities.
I make no claims about,
you know,
my Sensei's the people I've learned from being,
from on high the first day I rode a motorcycle.
I crashed it when flying through the air and was standing on my feet watching
the bike spin away because I was doing a Keto so much.
Oh,
I'm sure.
Well that's balance.
You know,
and you can,
there's a lot of videos of guys getting,
there's a great video of a guy getting rear ended while he's on a bike.
He flips through the air and lands on his feet.
Yeah.
And it just,
yeah,
it was thrown.
I landed on my shoulder on the,
on a street on tar and it was standing up watching the bike spin away with one
little tiny tear in my shoulder because I took the force of being thrown a,
the way I had my,
my body had been trained.
Well,
I'm definitely not saying that learning how to fall isn't a huge skill to have.
If you want to ride a motorcycle and fall down.
Learning how to fall is a big part of both judo and Jujitsu and a kito and a lot
of different martial arts.
But this motherfucker's not stopping anybody.
Okay.
Get him down telling you right now that'll do was close line technique.
Well this is hard to see what that kind of shit demonstrates.
It's also hard to pick apart,
you know,
from,
from here.
If you were in the,
in the Dojo watching the footwork,
you might perceive a little bit differently.
We're watching someone who is not a 90 year old guy with uh,
with uh,
uh,
um,
polite student.
Right.
You know,
there are different,
uh,
that's why I want to see some real shit.
I've never seen it.
I've,
I've every single one of those,
I mean,
I've seen some judo demonstrations where there was one that we played recently
was amazing.
There's this old Judah,
but the way he moved was logical.
I mean,
I understood that what he was doing was effective.
Yeah.
Based on my knowledge of the human body and movement.
That's not,
that's I'm done watching some cooperation there.
I'm watching the guy run into this guy's punches or this guy's forearms.
Got Anything Jammy?
No.
Uh,
Turkish wrestler versus a keep it open.
Okay,
that sounds interesting.
Yeah.
A Turkish wrestler versus an ICO guy.
Okay.
Let's say first of all,
the wrestle looks like he's about 60
and who knows if he's really a wrestler.
Take some town like I thought mount.
Exactly.
That's what I'm saying.
Tap some head and arm choke.
That's what I thought.
Now let's see this again.
Okay.
He's going to try it again.
Here he goes,
grabs him,
throws him to the ground again.
Grabs him,
drove him to the ground.
Yeah.
This is what I expected.
Exactly.
See,
this is what happens in real life.
This is what happens.
This is an arm bar.
This is a guy is not even good at armbars and needs the left leg over the face.
That's,
that's reality.
This shit doesn't work and it's a beautiful art to practice.
It looks cool,
but it's like as far as like efficacy and actual grappling against the scale,
but the goal is not skilled grappling.
The goal is to learn how force works when your body's flying through the air.
Right.
And when someone's punching in the face,
I learned how that force coming at you to be safe.
The goal is not to strike many I kido places don't even teach much in the way of
attacks.
Well that guy wasn't striking him.
That guy just grabbed him.
Right.
But I'm saying that it's not a me against you conflict art.
It is.
Let's work on playing around with forces that are moving between us together.
I totally understand that.
And I think it was initially developed to disarm people with a weapon when
someone would come at you with a weapon to use the energy of that weapon to take
it away from them.
I just think as far as an actual martial art,
it's one of the least effective in real practice.
I mean,
yeah,
but again,
the goal is not necessarily face to face combat.
You know,
if you,
you can pick other things that are more military and are trying to kill the,
what the goal is,
kill the goal is not killing or meeting force with force that goals,
keeping people safe.
Right.
I Quito life is to kill you or kill your opponent as quickly as possible.
Well that's why I labeled them.
That's why I brought up wrestling because wrestling the goals and kill you
either wrestling the goal,
well the goal is to control,
control your body,
which would be probably the most effective way to avoid getting hurt.
If you have someone coming at you,
if you can control their body,
they can't harm her.
Sure.
But controlling yourself is probably the,
the,
the higher,
uh,
focus on acute,
I would say.
I think you're fucking binds Mumbo jumbo.
Maybe.
Got You.
Maybe they do.
Maybe I've been,
I've been indoctrinated.
Wow.
This is still a long history of that stuff where it's like a part of people's,
a map of the world.
You know,
you have your model of the world of what's effective and what's not effective.
And one of the,
there's a lot of people that don't like the idea of mixed martial arts because
it's not in,
in many ways it's not traditional martial arts.
And some of the,
uh,
some of the positive benefits of traditional martial arts have sort of been cast
aside in favor of Mohawk tattooed savages.
Right?
Right.
But the reality is a lot of the ideas that powered those traditional martial
arts beliefs are bullshit.
And we thought they were real for a long time and there was only one way to find
out if they were real.
And that was competition.
And in competition you find that the reality is most of that stuff doesn't work.
But that's also competition.
I mean,
I've been attacked in bars,
you know,
spend,
grabs you in a bar and before they know it,
I'm standing next to them and they're not interested in attacking me anymore
because their wrist is,
you know,
in pain or they're on the ground or you know,
that that's happened to me.
I've used this stuff in real world environments,
not against some like,
you know,
professional wrestlers coming at me,
but against some asshole.
And a bar.
Right.
You know,
it's uh,
it's,
it's very valid.
It's very useful.
Okay.
What that means to me is it works great as long as the guy doesn't know what the
fuck he's doing.
Well we know martial arts isn't going to walk around trying to kick people's
asses.
That's what an unskilled asshole does.
Yeah.
But it's not,
that's not the point.
But that's not necessarily the true cause you could run into someone who was an
asshole who's skilled and just they have issues they have,
maybe they could have emotional issues.
There's a lot of people that are skilled fighters that go and pick fights,
I suppose.
And if you have Ikea Edo and they have that,
you're going to get fucked up.
No,
cause I'm not gonna engage with their fight.
I'm going to step aside when they,
you know,
and also these guys are drinking beer in the bar.
They're getting there.
They're,
they're drunk.
And you're in the bar too.
But I don't,
but I,
I don't get out of control with alcohol.
You're assuming they do though.
I think absolutely.
I'm assuming they knew martial arts.
We'll work on trained killers and a kito just doesn't,
okay.
It's just,
I don't want to shatter beliefs,
but this is,
uh,
an important subject to me because it's something that I went through my entire
adult life and as a young man,
I,
I kinda went through the broad spectrum of what to believe in,
what not to be even.
I have no problem that is not a competitive martial art and you know,
it doesn't,
it doesn't work the way wrestling or,
or a Krav Maga or karate or judo.
I'm okay with it being not a practical as those,
I still think there's incredible benefit in learning to use your body and keep
yourself safe in a crisis environment.
Well,
there's,
there's benefit in gymnastics.
You know,
there's a benefit in a lot of different things that I would look,
one of the best
platforms for going into Jujitsu,
we've were recently finding his breakdancing.
Hmm.
These breakdancing guys,
there's a whole team of them from 10th Planet Jiu Jitsu that started out as
breakdancers.
And these guys have these incredible athletic ability because they learned how
to support themselves on one hand and hand stands and spin around and they can
manipulate their bodies and these incredibly unique ways.
And these guys mean you'd never think of break dancing being a martial art,
but one once these guys learned basic positions,
there are so good
at them because they're,
I would say that the same is true for Nike Doka.
You can take someone who's learned that and put them in a more,
you know,
hard form.
They're going to have skills that descend from balanced posture,
moving around your center and moving from a strong ploys.
I would agree.
You know,
certainly I just would,
I would be real concern and this is one of the reasons why I'm so adamant about
this.
I'm very nervous about people getting inaccurate ideas on their head and I've
seen it in action.
I mean,
we used to have guys,
when I was my competition days,
they would come to the gym that had come from some crazy kung fu martial art
where they had this distorted perception of reality and they would spar with
people who actually knew how to fight and they would get knocked out.
It's just horrible to watch because they had this idea in their head of who they
were.
And then in practice it just didn't work.
Like Quito Center has an idea of themselves as a sparring fighter.
That's not what they have.
The idea of themselves as how well they would be able to keep something away
from them.
Uh,
yeah.
If somebody grabs them or comes running out there that we just saw a guy tackled
over and over again,
very easily shared.
But the,
you know,
I wouldn't let that guy tackled me.
I just,
I just wouldn't have been there.
What do you mean you wouldn't have been there?
He would've come at me.
I would've stepped to one side.
And just not what you think that guy wanted to do that?
No cause he was,
he was trying for a specific technique.
He just like grabbed my arm and I'll,
I'll do the technique I'm thinking of.
So do you think that if you were in a mad at room with someone who's a trained
grapple,
you'd be able to keep them away from you for longer than that guy?
Yeah.
Maybe not much longer.
You got to try that.
A lot of people have ideas in their head of what is possible,
but you got to put that in action.
I'm also heavily trained in restraining people.
How so?
I mean,
I restrain people in psych hospitals for several years.
That was my job.
Crazy people flipping out and throwing chairs,
you know,
six foot,
five,
300 pound people that I can restrain them alone often or with one other person.
You know,
one of the things that I think will be really interesting to talk to you about
it specifically is what is going on in the mindset of someone who is engaging in
conflict because one of the most important aspects of any physical altercation
is being able to keep your wits about you.
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
violence conflict causes a huge surge in adrenaline,
cortisol,
which is a stress hormone and it shuts down the connections between the,
the executive,
the CEO of the brain and the other parts of the brain that we sort of have a
dual track brain or mind almost.
We have topped down resources and bottom up resources says automatic things that
happened.
Like I can't look at the picture behind you about seeing it.
The bottom up,
it's automatic and then there's top down.
You know,
how I interpret what I'm seeing or how I decide to feel about it.
That's bought,
you know,
a top down versus bottom up.
Um,
a lot of the bottom up stuff and crisis and violence is what takes over and the
top down ability to,
for your,
your intentions,
your perceptions,
your moment to moment perspective on your brain or on your reality that goes
away in a crisis.
And the PFC,
the prefrontal cortex gets shut down or least it's connections between the PFC
and the rest of the brain gets shut down a little bit and you go into automatic
deal with the crisis mode.
I wish we could monitor that in competitive martial arts contest because I've
seen it time and time again where people are professionals and they have a long
experience of competition,
but they get to the big event,
whether it's fighting for the world championship,
fighting a contender,
the main event on a big show and they freeze.
Totally see,
you see the nerves you see readily kicks up and you know,
yeah,
I used to be in college,
I was a fencer,
uh,
and I fenced a lot,
you know,
weapons and um,
most of the time it's pretty chill and lefthanded which has an advantage in
fencing often.
And so I was pretty,
I was pretty good at,
at my school,
I was one of the better people.
But then you go to these big events and the adrenaline kicks in and there's,
you know,
spectators,
the crowd,
it's a very different environment.
You know,
I can state dependent learning where you learn skills in one set of contexts.
And if the context change too much,
the skills may not be there.
So these fighters who get to the big event haven't practiced in the big event
room or with enough noise or enough flooding or enough,
you know,
caring about the fight,
right.
To the point where they can bring the same resources online that they learned.
You know,
it's like musicians.
Uh,
I'm sure you know some musicians who can't play unless they're stoned because
that's the only way they've ever played music.
Bri state dependent learning.
So that's,
that's a,
that's always overblown.
It's not quite as dramatic and effect as we think it is.
You see it with standup comedy too.
You see some,
sometimes people can work well with small crowds,
very little pressure.
And then if you put them in front of a large crowd there,
you literally see them constrict.
Yeah.
And some of that's the sweet spot they're used to living in,
right?
There's the,
there's the stress response curve.
It's an inverted u,
the Yerkes Dodson curve and a little bit of stress.
It's a stress versus performance on two axes.
A little bit of stress means better performance,
a little more stress,
better performance,
performance plateaus.
A little more stress,
performance degrades and this can be like stress or is like I'm stressed out or
just physiological arousal,
heart beating,
you know,
getting ready to do something.
A little bit of this stuff is good.
A lot of it is not good.
And if you're not used to existing,
not used to performing in a mode on the far end of that curve,
your performance is gone.
Yeah.
Seems like there's a wall that they hit that's unexpected and then they just get
this like,
I didn't think this wall was going to be there.
Now what?
Well,
they used to performing somewhere in the top of the curve where they're stressed
out enough or there are physiologically aroused enough to perform very,
very well,
but a little more stress reaction times down,
judgments,
down,
awareness,
memory,
learning.
All these things are impaired in that sense.
Do you think there's anything that you could do that would help athletes compete
under massive amounts of pressure?
Yeah,
I do actually.
Um,
this sleep spend,
all that we tend to train up called Smr,
sensory motor rhythm in the brain seems to improve athletic performance.
It's used a lot in golfers who are trying to get in the zone.
Um,
and the way,
and you know,
most neurofeedback is as non voluntary operant shaping,
but with golfers,
you follow them around the golf course with a laptop and when their brain goes
in and they get ready to,
they tee up and get ready to strike the ball,
um,
and then they wait until the computer makes a noise and tells them,
okay,
you're in the zone now.
And then they release and you hit the ball.
And so they're,
they're trying to associate being in the feeling of being in the zone with
performing,
with,
you know,
delivering the,
the golf pulse,
the club swing or something.
Is it one of those things,
it's very difficult to replicate because a lot of times being in the zone means
almost like you're,
you're in that Zen state,
right?
Which is why you're training the brain to go there again and again and again and
to know,
and you're,
and you're giving an audit,
an audio cue.
So you start to recognize,
oh,
that tone means zone.
That's what it feels like right now.
Okay.
And if you reinforce that association,
if you pointing at that state and sang up there it is,
there's your brains in that state,
you get sort of more able to access.
It is a difficult term to replicate when you have a guy there with a laptop,
it seems like a for,
for golfing and is,
there's several sports and performance oriented neurofeedback approaches these
days and they all are somewhat similar,
you know,
reducing the stress response and increasing attention to keep you in that sweet
spot to some extent.
You know,
it would be fascinating if you monitored the brainwaves of fighters leading
right up to the moment you got,
they got into the cage and then take the equipment off of them,
let them compete and then find out where the winners were when they stepped in
and were the losers were that might work.
I'm the brain off sometimes changes states very,
very quickly.
And so,
you know,
because it's a lead up to an event,
you probably would get relevant data.
Um,
but you know,
I,
you're right,
you have to take the equipment off when you're actually physically moving
around.
So especially if you're going to get hit,
I just movement muscles are also electrical.
Okay.
And so any muscle movement causes a burst of noise,
which swamps the brain measurements.
So you would get a lot of noise even if they're warming up.
Yeah,
it wouldn't really work.
pretty much.
So you'd have to kind of measure them like in stillness as they were about to
step into the cage and that would take too much time.
It might not.
I mean,
depends on what you're measuring.
When I do assessments,
it's a full head of EEG and gel caps and things,
but you can stick a single wire and ear clip on someone's head and measure EEG.
How long would it take?
30 seconds.
That might be worth studying,
but the measure for 32nd baseline or something?
Yeah,
I don't know.
I don't know enough about it,
but I would think that there would be some interesting data that you would get
based on.
I mean it would be really fascinating if we found out,
well,
look at this.
All of the winners.
We're in this zone and all of the losers were in this area.
Yeah,
you'd probably find increased fast alpha sort of flow state.
Um,
you know,
a lot of Beta but not a lot of very fast beta.
So focus but not anxiety.
Um,
probably very low amount of slow brainwaves like Delta and which happened when
you're dreaming or creative or checked out.
So my guess is,
as you know,
the performance would be correlated with better access to flow states and focus
states and less presence of anxiety states and distractable states.
There's so much to learn when it comes to the human mind.
This is such a fascinating subject of conversation because most people have no
idea of what's going on below the surface.
It's like we have this unbelievably powerful supercomputer that's running our
reality and we don't have a clue as to how to operate it.
The most complicated machine,
we know about three pounds,
but more connections in the brain.
Then there are stars in the galaxy.
Yeah.
When I did this,
a infinite monkey cage with Brian Cox recently,
and they were talking about how much more complex a frog is in the universe.
Yeah,
I'm like,
I'm done.
I can't.
You can't.
Radically,
the human brain can store more bits of information than there are atoms in the
universe.
Now we don't store all that information,
but we're never going to run out of storage space.
The,
and this is a bit of a cheat,
but the,
the rubric for that is,
um,
you take the number of neurons,
you have,
let's say $100 billion,
we have more but 100 billion,
and you think about the connections they can make with other neurons.
So a hundred billion neurons tied to a hundred billion neurons,
and let's ignore recurrent connections.
And then let's ignore our connections from one neuron to multiple,
which does absolutely happen.
It's actually the rule versus the exception.
And let's ignore the fact that glial cells,
which are also in brain cells are also computational.
Let's just take the neurons and just take the neurons connected to all the
neurons.
So number of neurons raised to the power of the number of neurons.
So $100 billion raised the power of 100 billion.
That number is larger than the estimate of atoms in the universe,
Jesus Christ.
So you can store more bits of information.
Then there are bits of information,
Denton saying we should end with that.
Perfect.
It's the ultimate mind.
Fuck Ladies and gentlemen.
Wow.
You're welcome.
Thank you very much man.
It's been so amazing.
Amazing conversation.
Really fascinating.
Um,
your stuff that people,
if you're interested,
it's called true brain.
This is the,
a nootropic blended,
the three different ones.
Uh,
I tried,
they're the one with caffeine,
which you said taste the least good and it was pretty good.
Um,
and your center is called alternatives as brain institute.
We can get,
you can ask this to both the websites@alternativesbh.com which is behavioral
health and then true brain tru,
brain.com.
Really,
really fascinating.
Thank you very much.
Really appreciate you coming on.
Alright Ladies and gentlemen,
we'll be back in a couple of hours with Duncan Trussell.
So while we'll see them much love.
Bye.
Cool.